this is jacqueline podcast number 330
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening
a little after midnight
on thanksgiving
1943 while patrolling the black waters
off cape st george near new guinea
burke's five-ship wolf pack
spotted a japanese radar contact
immediately and without permission
burke radioed his squadron hold your
hats boys here we go
into the dark and into the enemy's guns
burke's destroyers drop throttles to
flank speed and launch torpedoes
exploding two japanese ships outright
then wheeled the starboard
like the parthian horses archers
into the face of three more enemy ships
that immediately tucked tail and fled
in the night-long pursuit burke's deck
sailors discharged and loaded their guns
so fast and so long that many passed out
in their turrets from the fumes and from
sheer exhaustion
when burke's squadron finally returned
to port
said a time magazine reporter every ship
in the roadstead turned up its
searchlights and every blue jacket in
the fleet manned the rails in tribute
it was halsey said afterward the classic
c action of this war
for 13 months burke commanded his
destroyers like patton did his tanks
to every order he invariably responded
proceeding at 31 knots
a boiler bursting pace said one
historian that caught admiral william
bull halsey's attention who addressed
the few his future dispatches to 31 not
burke
the name stuck
in the last two years the war burke was
forced to give up command of his own
squadron in order to become chief of
staff to mark michener a famous aircraft
carrier admiral neither a pilot nor
possessing any experience in aircraft
carriers burke was at first out of place
in the new staff role an onlooker to the
aviators in a jolt to his morale that
almost immediately expanded to his
waistline
essentially confined to the flag plot
the ship's tactical command center burke
was forced not only to learn everything
he could about aircraft carriers and
their tactics but also to elevate his
operational understanding
beyond the amateur's urge for the battle
at hand in order to plan for the next
one
beyond the marianas to the philippine
sea
beyond that to leyte gulf then on to iwo
jima when submarine intelligence told
him the battleship yama yamoto was
spotted en route to an unknown location
he spent all night hunched over his
charge
charts a caliper in hand
then launched 400 planes against the
spot where he would be if the rolls were
reversed
and sank the ship with more than three
thousand men aboard
before his planes returned burke had
already switched his attention to the
next battle by the time they reached
okinawa the final terrible fight of the
world war of world war ii burkitt
settled into a punishing routine always
up at 0-330 the sleep he did manage was
usually interrupted by some 20 calls a
night in his waking hours burke watched
nightmares unfold his only sanctuary the
flashes of courage that for years to
come said a biographer would seem to
whisper to him something about the
meaning of the us navy
the worst of these and the greatest
was the final transmission of a newly
commissioned ensign who had taken
command of his crippled destroyer after
everyone else in his chain of command
had been killed
before the ship sank and the
transmission was cut off burke heard the
young man say
quote
i will fight this ship to the best of my
ability and forgive me the mistakes i am
about to make end quote
that voice would haunt
and steal him for the rest of his life
and that
is an
emotion and a haunting
that i think many of us feel
did i do enough to train the young
leaders that followed me
and the answer
always seems to be no i could have done
more i could have passed on more lessons
learned i could have done a better job
teaching
our operational history to the next
generation so that they would not repeat
the mistakes we made
but there's so much to teach and there's
so much to learn and there's so many
lessons to pass on
and sometimes lessons don't get passed
on
they get forgotten
and only
the deepest of dedication and research
and commitment can bring
those lessons back
and that reading that i opened with was
an excerpt
from the book
the book is called by water beneath the
walls
which was
written by a friend of mine
a seal teammate of mine
by the name of ben milligan ben has been
on this podcast before it's podcast
number 298.
go listen to that if you haven't
listened to it yet but on that podcast
we discuss where ben came from how he
ended up in the seal teams
and how he ended up writing this
this incredible book which took him
seven years to write
and the book is
is an amazing book i think this is the
most important historical book i have
ever read on the seal teams and i think
it actually might be
the most important book on special
operations as a whole that i have read
and if you haven't
read this book buy it immediately
it is absolutely an incredible look
at the history of the seal teams but it
ties in
so
many other aspects of the military and
special operations and the wars we've
been through
and
the amount of commitment that it took to
write this this
one
amount of commitment that can come from
only someone with ben's
personality and his his drive to find
out and unravel history and we're lucky
enough to have ben back with us to
discuss
more of these incredible accounts of
history's uh history from the seal teams
and of the entire community of
special operations
so ben thanks for coming back man thanks
jacob it's great to be here
and
uh
thanks for that section too it's one of
my favorite sections in the book um
i i
it
one of the hardest things you do when
you write a book is uh you have to edit
it and you have to cut it and i think we
talked about that last time this was one
of those
sections that i had
probably 15 more pages just on burke
that had i had to drop my that chapter
had been completely structured
differently i had started with burke um
at his change of command ceremony when
he became the cno and then i rolled into
you know this you know 15 page just uh
it was my biggest uh
introduction of a character um
even bigger probably than draper
kaufman's i justified that in my head
when i was writing it because i always
felt like burke or at least when i
discovered burke when i discovered his
contribution to the creation of the seal
teams i felt like
uh next to um
phil bucklow
arleigh burke is the indispensable man
he um the seal teams would not have
existed without him without uh and and
the um
it wouldn't have existed without his
biography that he just consolidated into
you know this
um
complete preoccupation with keeping the
navy connected to offensive warfare
and and
there was just example after example of
his time in world war ii uh you know
there were he was in
at least two um uh two vessels being
shot out from under him or two two
vessels were sunk by the japanese that
he had to and
he had to escape from and in each uh
instance of his escape he was leaving
behind every possession that he had
every possession that he had gone
through the war with uh and in the
process he was rescuing guys around him
uh and in one case uh he risked his life
going uh into a completely um
uh
uh smoke-filled passageway uh to rescue
a uh
i think it was a seaman like a radio a
radio man um and he's the you know the
chief of staff of the ship and
no business he'd
get off the ship but he's you know
saving the sailors around him
um
but yeah he was like you like you
mentioned in your
um your opening uh
the
his
commitment to passing on what he had
learned
not just what he had learned but
his belief in what the navy was to that
next generation that's what kept him as
a cno for six years as like i say in the
book it's
two years longer than any even the
closest competitor cno is normally just
a two-year spot
admiral king um who's uh the cno during
world war ii he serves for four but
after king nobody else comes close
except burke and burke's there for six
years
and whenever i know that you you know
you take pictures of your watch and you
start working at 4 30.
um which is funny because i often
thought that i should start taking a
picture of my watch when i sit down on
my computer to start writing
i'm not sure it would be as motivating
but
whenever i hear somebody talk about how
you have to uh get eight hours of sleep
at night sleep's the most important
thing i'm like
man i know that you're wrong and i know
it because of burke
i know it because of every you know
other people these high achievers like
somebody like burke he never slept
uh
yeah that why that passage stood out to
me um and look i've got so many marks in
this book now uh from the last time we
did this and just from reading it but
that idea
that
here's this guy who's listening to a
young ensign
go down with his ship and he's thinking
to himself you know after this guy says
forgive me the mistakes i'm about to
make and you know arleigh burke sitting
there thinking
he could have taught him he could have
given him a heads up he could have given
whoever that commander was or the
lieutenant commander or the the
lieutenant that was above this guy in
the chain of command all these guys
could he could have taught them
something that maybe they wouldn't be in
this situation and just knowing that
every effort that you gave to to pass on
the lessons they failed and now this
this guy is this young man this young
ensign is dying and he's going to go
down with his ship with all these
sailors on board and
there's
there's just all these lessons and and
i mean there's so many times when when i
was in the teams
well a good example is mike thornton
you know mike thornton came on this
podcast a couple years ago and we went
moment by moment and debriefed
the the operation where he
for which he was awarded the medal of
honor
and it's it's three hours it's like a
three hour debrief
and i was in the seal teams
with at the same time as mike thornton
i knew mike thornton
i had met mike thornton on several
occasions i'd spent time with mike
thornton
but i'd never gotten like a full debrief
of what happened
and you think to yourself all those
lessons that didn't get passed on until
he came on the podcast and told me like
all these little lessons
and then you start thinking about
someone like burke or
or this entire book that you've written
where there's just all these lessons
that are completely forgotten
and well i should say they're almost
completely forgotten i don't know that
they're completely forgotten i know i
know the point you're trying to make and
i agree like
um
since the book has come out i've been
keeping a list there's been 12
uh 12 guys that i interviewed in the
course of the book that aren't with us
anymore
and
i always think like what would have
happened if i had started the book a
year late or a year later than i did or
what opportunities did i miss because i
started the book when i did and not two
years earlier like how many how many
stories did i miss or how many lessons
did i miss
um the one thing though that i think
about when i think of like um
you know somebody who's as young as that
ensign was in the in the section that
you read um who's going down i mean that
ensign mike thornton when he's i think
mike thornton was 25 when he rescued
tommy norris
um
he's not old enough i mean he's old
enough to he's a he's a grown man i mean
he's uh
um
he he has a 25 year old's perspective on
life but he doesn't have all the context
that you know that you and i have and
echo and we've lived long lives i mean
we've we've been around here for a
minute and we've collected stories and
we've collected context um
and we have uh
you know enough um
you know ammunition you know whether
it's marley or
or whatever to
help us or to convince us to to to make
right decisions
but somebody's 25 years old with this
ensign i imagine this ensign you know
probably 22 years old
like
he doesn't know anything he doesn't know
anything about the world he hasn't heard
you know uh stories you know like the
one that you just read
um
but what he does have uh he has this uh
he's been imprinted by the institution
that he served in and by the people that
are around him
um
and that's i think that's an important
uh thing that you know buzz does or
bootcamp does you're you're taking uh
young folks and you know from lots of
different backgrounds and without you
know the context that we have as you get
older and you read books and and you
have these experiences but you imprint
you know the values of that institution
on these people and you give them uh new
mandates for what's expected
um
and that's cool
and i appreciate that
but
you know like i said this this ensign
wasn't in charge of the ship right there
was a there was an exo there was a co
there was an ops boss that are all now
dead
and
even with the imprints of kind of the
broad value system that we have
in the navy or the broad value system
that you have in the marine corps the
broad value system that you have in the
army
there are actual tactics that you can
know that can save your ass in certain
situations
and you know i
when i was in trade
like i remember sometimes especially
when i first got home from ramadi i'd be
watching a guy move through the streets
and in mount training right
and i would feel like sick to my stomach
if a guy wasn't taking cover
and
it's a really simple thing that hey
someone tells you hey listen man only
move from cover to cover don't ever be
in a spot where you're standing and
you're not in cover don't ever let that
happen when you're not behind cover
you're moving that's the way it is
obviously it wasn't instinctual to a
bunch of people coming through you know
advanced seal training coming through
workup there would be
out of every 10 new guys there would be
three of them that would stand around in
the open like nothing's gonna happen to
them
and so there's there's instincts and
that's why when i read this past i was
like
the feeling of the sickness that i can
only imagine is even worse for him
because he's thinking here's another
ship with however many 300 souls going
down on it and
i know that
i could have had them you know do
do whatever they could have done
differently right and and the lessons
just didn't get passed on
and that's why to me this book that
you've written is so important because
it does have lessons that i saw i saw us
relearn some of the lessons that you've
got in this book i watched this happen
and so
i
i'm glad look i'm i wish you would have
written it earlier right i wish you
would have written it 10 years ago or 15
years ago but you didn't because you're
lazy
but it took you seven years to write
this thing um
and the lessons are are just they're
just awesome and they're important
and you know you know
the whole dynamic when you understand
the whole dynamic
of
where
this personality comes from where this
mode of operating that that is sort of
look the seal teams everyone every sale
is a little bit different but there's
some core things there that are
that they're going to be there no matter
what seal you talk to from what
generation they've got this
they got a couple things in their soul
and when people start to un those things
can fade
but when people start to understand
where that thing that little nugget in
their soul where that came from and they
go oh that's actually not just a that's
not just a rock that's a cornerstone and
we should focus on that we should
remember that we should know where that
came from we should know why that was
important that we had that
characteristic or we had that that that
way of thinking about things
and
for me this book illuminated so many
threads of the thought process that we
have as seals where they came from to
make sure when someone says well you
know
we we need to just fall in line with
another i know actually we don't need to
just follow mine there's a reason that
we think this way there's a reason that
it's beneficial there's a reason that
it's beneficial to keep an open mind
there's a reason that it's beneficial to
utilize decentralized command there's a
reason for those things and we should
never forget where they came from and
the more we understand where they came
from the more we can act upon them
correctly
right
so
with that i'm sorry your book gets me
super fired up about something more than
i say
so this uh
uh my idea and i don't know how well
we're gonna be able to stick this idea
um because you have way too much
freaking you have way too many facts and
stories running around in your head and
i've got too many questions running
around in mine but my idea was to try
and go through some of the chapters and
like you just did you just said you got
about 15 pages cut out 15 pages of
arleigh burke by the way did you
actually write those 15 pages yeah yeah
they're written oh yeah i mean i had
that's horrible some of it's like you
know extreme some of it's like someone's
notes no no no i mean it's all written
it was all like i mean
i mean i have a not a paragraph but i
have a couple sentences on burke's wife
i'm like
all right i need
not all of this needs to be here
you know but when you find like
i don't know
your experience but when you're editing
like if you're writing a novel i expect
like
the uh the impulse when you're you know
cutting stuff
is that you know you have a turn of
phrase that you really like and you're
like oh man that is
i mean that's the best thing that's been
written since the bible
and you don't want to get rid of it and
your editor tells you well nobody gets
what you're trying to say it sucks you
know you need to lose it
um
but i think when you're you know when
you're writing history uh and you're
you've done all this research you've
followed you know
you know so many rabbit holes you've
done so many requests the navy yard or
wherever you've gotten your material
and you've found what you think you
think is this incredible document
you want to use that stuff you you mean
you fought for it i mean you want to put
it in there
i mean i
um
i have a lot of detail in each sentence
i i don't do that you know to
make a reader you know frustrated i have
it because
you know i'm i'm the way that i'm
writing is i have four note cards that
i'll sit in front of me and those four
note cards you will usually have you
know two or three points on them i'll
star which one which point i have on
each note card i'll be like i want to
put that that and that in one sentence
how do i do that like how do i fit all
that you know stuff in there so yes i
did i cut probably between 10 and 15
pages of burke's biography
however when i when i rewrote the
chapter
i didn't completely lose that i mean i
try to say that i i left as much on the
field as possible i just you know
compressed it into this really really
you know tight diamond of of information
but yeah everybody i mean i i there were
whole characters that i cut and i got
better as time went on so um
when i was thinking about how we were
going to do this and i started to go
back through you know chapter by chapter
you know what were sections that i cut
what were sections that i lost and
you know not just characters but entire
episodes i saw
i saw in these chapters my notes that i
was putting together were getting
shorter and shorter and shorter each
chapter because i was learning as i was
doing this whole book and i did my
research and i did my writing chapter by
chapter i would research and write one
chapter i would go back to an archive
i'd collect all the stuff and i'd write
that next chapter and then i'd do it
again for the third chapter for whatever
i was doing
and i got better as i went um
better at identifying what
what was going to fit and also you must
have seen a better of clearer vision of
the story arc yes and so you knew what
was important what was not yeah much
better much better idea of the story uh
and much better um respect for my reader
because i was you know when i was
reading this i was completely in love
with my own pen i thought everything i
wrote was fantastic i wrote the first
chapter so well
you know i probably should just send
this off to the pulitzer committee
so they have just you know have this
thing up front they'll they'll know
what's coming eventually
um
but you know when i reread that chapter
six months after i'd written it i saw i
was like
i'm not sure why that character's in
here
it's like oh that i don't know about him
either like yeah i found myself i had
like i i i did five introductions of
five different characters in that first
chapter before i really got to carlson
and his raiders like the hell was i
doing
like i don't even know why i spent all
that time doing it like i was just but i
was learning you know you're learning
the process and you're learning how to
get better as you go
um
but yeah you seem to think about the
you seem to think about the reader a lot
more than i do are you like oh i don't
want to put the reader through this i'm
like well i'm the reader i mean i mean
i'm the reader i'm my imagination i mean
i'm i'm my own reader like i wrote like
i said i i wrote the book that i wanted
to read
and i you know
but like you
you have to think about your your reader
you have to or at least i felt felt like
i have to think about my reader because
otherwise i'm writing a diary i don't
want to write a diary i want people to
read what i'm writing i guess the
closest i would come to is like oh does
this would this make sense if i was
reading it so yeah i guess yeah you
think about the reader a little bit
you're your reader you're i mean i don't
think about the reader it sounds like
you think about the readers
sympathetically they're getting no
sympathy for me you're like well i don't
want to put the reader through hit the
reader on board with this
i i don't know if i like i
my reader was uh
um
i wanted it to be i wanted my reader to
be you know a team guy i wanted this
book to be for the seals but i wanted my
mom to be able to read it too so that
when i was thinking like when i wrote
this paragraph up
uh was it sufficiently dense was it
sufficiently was there was there enough
material in it or enough interesting
things on that to you know to make me
like oh that's that's good stuff but was
it also written well enough that my mom
could understand it that's what i was
thinking about
well also the last time that we were on
here yeah and you asked me what my mom
did and i just said that she was a
housewife
how'd that go it didn't go over great so
what's the real deal
uh
i don't i don't have a credit
my mom was everything she did everything
you set yourself up
my mom did everything she was uh she was
god she was the chief of staff there you
go that's a that sounds better than
housewife i guess yeah um unless you're
a badass housewife in which case you're
like yeah i'm a badass housewife what's
up
we know what that entails that means i'm
the
the the chief staff officer the chief
financial officer the troop motivator
you're everything yeah getting after it
so there you go moms
so now she can stop being mad at me six
months later
all right so my my thought was we go
through this and talk about some of the
because you know you and i had
conversations during the during the
podcast after the podcast about the
amount of people the same thing you're
saying right now you had to just cut
things out cut stories out yeah and
so many of these things can can be their
own book can be their own story you
could peel pull back the pull the thread
on any of these characters and you could
you could you have your own you have
another book on just about any of these
characters
um
but i thought just going through some of
the chapters going through the chapters
and talking about some of the things
that didn't quite make it
uh chapter one
is called the reluct by the way i was
thinking about this as i was putting
this together chapter one is called the
reluctant creation and violent demise of
the navy's first commandos the marine
corps raiders your subtitles for each
chapter indicate that you have a lot to
say this is going to be a long book like
chapter one they're reluctant you know
my books have like chapter one get some
you know boom we're done right chapter
two get more like i'm an idiot you're
over here the reluctant creation and
violent demise of the navy's first
commandos the marine corps raiders
uh that was my editors that was julian
pavilla he uh he sort of insisted so
each of my chapters were something like
i don't know like it wasn't it wasn't as
uh as tight as like carlson's raiders
but it was something like
the the only one that i remember is for
chapter five for my udts it was like the
the merman of war before they had come
up with the frogmen as like a moniker
for them they were calling them like the
really clunky oh god that's awful
especially after that move what's that
movie echo charles which one uh
zoolander
you know what i'm talking about so in
the movie zoolander
uh which has
owen wilson in it yeah who's like one of
my favorite people of all time that guy
seems so chill and cool
and it also has ben stiller ben stiller
so ben stiller plays like a really dumb
model as a man model right
and he comes from some freaking mining
town in pennsylvania or something and
he's in this bar with his dad he's
trying to be like more manly
and his dad's in there
and his dad's played by uh john voight
john voigt they're all they're all like
covered in mind gusts vince vaughn's in
there no lines no lines just no lunch
just being tough
and
so
ben stiller's in there trying to be
tougher
and a and a commercial comes on the tv
and it's him advertising some like
fragrance
and he's dressed up like a mermaid
and his dad's like i can't have you
running around here as a damn mermaid
he's it's not a mermaid dad it's merman
so that's what i thought of when i saw
that thing i was reading through
yesterday i'm like did we really have to
go there with the merman
clunky's at the least all right so so
but my yes so his point was you need to
give the reader some idea of what's in
store for them like if you start a
chapter
on the
if okay so
imagine you're a reader you're picking
up a book uh ostensibly about the navy
seals and that first chapter is you know
you're reading paid you know three pages
and it's all about the marine corps what
the hell are you doing you have to give
you know your reader some idea of what
this is about and
you know when i
when i thought about it you know it
completely made sense because you know
now i'm not just doing
the you know the reader you know help on
chapter one with the marine corps
raiders but i'm gonna help i'm gonna be
helping the reader when it gets to the
army rangers and everything else like it
has to tie back in each of these
chapters had to tie back in uh to the
seal teams it had to be relevant to you
know how the navy had you know created
this first
yeah well that's why we have the clunky
that's why you have a big long big long
titles for all your chapters you're one
of these guys that pulls off like hey if
i'm just really nice maybe jocko will
leave me alone
you're like you gave this super nice
explanation now i kind of feel bad like
no that's a good title you know
you did good you put me in check all
humble and i'm all right
i'm a jerk i'll just go i'll leave
so uh
marine corps um
let's talk about this chapter i know one
of the guys that you mentioned to me is
a guy named pete ellis
peters he didn't make the cut huh
no i thought pete ellis pete ellis is
relevant because pete ellis is the um
he's the marine he's a
first world war marine who is
um
he's the first marine to articulate a
vision for the marine corps that is more
than just a
subordinate service to the u.s navy or
the navy's police force he imagines
after he sees what the marine corps is
capable of on the western front um
the marine corps is the
when world war one starts
and
the us military finds itself in the
trenches not just in the trenches but
then moving on the german army
the
best force that the united states
military has is the marine corps
so there's all these marine officers
staff officers marine commanders who
suddenly by comparison with their peers
in the us army
see that the marine corps is the best
service the most capable service um you
know we have so why not you know start
thinking beyond you know just this idea
of being you know the ship war or the
ship born utility force for the us navy
why not start thinking of the us marine
corps as almost a rival to the u.s army
so in order to do that in order to
justify that in congress
the marine corps had to articulate a
mission for itself and that mission
uh was you know it was essentially come
up with by pete ellis pete ellis uh he
identifies the enemy or at least you
know he's writing this in 1922
20 years before world war ii starts he
knows that the next war the u.s is in is
going to be with imperial japan he knows
how rapacious japan is he knows uh their
ambitions to dominate all of asia and if
the u.s military wants to
confront japan it's going to have to
have a force capable of doing that a
force that's not just
you know
like i said the ship-borne
utility force of raiders or jungle
fighters anything like that they're
going to have to have all the logistics
capable of supporting
an amphibious army ashore artillery
aircraft
logistics ships landing craft all that
stuff so he is the one that comes up
with this plan problem with pete ellis
is he
is a personal disaster
he is
nobody
that i wrote about is
as much of a liberty risk i mean he is
uh he he suffers from depression um
something they call neurasnia uh and he
uh whenever he when he's writing this
plan the advanced base operations for
micronesia when he's writing when he's
drafting this plan for the marine corps
he's doing periodic bouts
at the mental hospital in washington dc
he um
eventually did what did he do in world
war one he was a staff officer but i i
i wasn't completely clear on his combat
record i got the sense that he actually
saw a decent amount of combat he um
he
wrote a plan of operations for i can't
remember which assault it was i think it
was on the uh blanc monk section of the
hindenburg line but it was it was
supposed it was supposed to be a
brilliant operational plan and it was it
was totally successful um
and uh
it was i think it was noticed by
pershing at one point um it was called
one of the best plans in the war
but after that uh
you know when he's you know during this
period of the twenties
um
after one bout in a mental institution
he convinces the secretary of the navy
or the under secretary of the navy which
is theodore roosevelt jr at the time to
send him on a like on an island hopping
uh survey of the central pacific so he
can justify her so he can prove what he
suspects which is the japanese are
building all these island readouts
throughout the throughout the pacific
he gets the authorization by teddy
roosevelt jr he goes out there
something happens at one of these island
bars he starts announcing uh his
intentions uh well he's on a bender
the spies try and like
collect him and get him packed off he
managed to manage it to escape
escapes the island makes his way to
another island and then drinks himself
to death
there's a you know there's a whole
cottage industry of uh
of writers out there that you know say
that uh he was poisoned or he was killed
by the japanese i think he was just a
drunk and he just
his liver couldn't handle it you're a
train i don't know what the name of the
place is but for a while
we were using some facility and i don't
want to name it but
you'll know what i'm talking about that
was used to be an institution like a
mental institution do you train in that
place uh
boy that sounds familiar for a while we
and the teams were going to some place
that was formerly a mental institution
and it was
creepy
creepy like you'd go into certain
east coast or west coast it's in the
middle of the country kind of i don't
know that i was there um
man it was weird you'd go into rooms and
you just like look around and
there'd be weird
it was weird it was really weird it you
know uh
like you get a little bit of scariness
you know what i'm saying where you know
it's night and you you're with like one
other dude and you're standing some
weird hallway and they're it's it looks
like it's from 1922 that's what made me
think of it like 1922 well
you know when you start talking about
what a mental institution was like in
1922 it's not like what it's like now
right right now it's you know probably
they've got nice windows and they want
to make things safe and open for people
to understand and learn and feel good
about themselves this was not the
scenario in this place where i trained
that at all man like what like an asylum
yes no 100 percent it was kind of yeah
it was like an asylum you thought it was
haunted that's why you're scared kind of
i think there's probably justifiable
reason to think that too i mean when you
you see like not just you know asylums
but uh there's this been there's been
this story of this uh
orphanage in canada you know that had
all these indigenous children they're
finding uh just mass massive burial
plots now of all these kids that were
killed there
that's horrific
yeah
well that was uh i'm not an expert on
that for anything yeah well that was
that was one of the goals was to uh just
to re-educate the children
you see it happening now right now with
our school systems kids are getting
re-educated in a new way
speaking of ending up in asylums
so
uh
there's another character
that's uh
yeah yeah a a guy named uh red mike
yeah i was hoping you'd ask about him
you could write a book about red mike
that's um red mike edson he's uh
so when um
i was trying to you know sort through
the uh
the relevance of the raiders
the raiders are important to
the history of the seal teams because
they're the first instance where the
navy telegraphs its desire for its own
raiding force
they want to
broadcast or they want to
franchise raids throughout the pacific
to draw the japanese attention away from
the areas that they're about to attack
so japanese defenses are too
consolidated they want to spread them
out on all these islands so
when before
the invasion of guadalcanal
it was the navy's idea to pull the
japanese attention all the way to the
central pacific you know 2 000 miles
north
so the idea is
launch some submarine raiders on these
things
um
and uh you know like i said spread the
spread japanese attention spread
japanese defenses um and i was looking i
knew that you know i knew that that's
that was the goal and there were two uh
raider battalions that do it or that
were designed to do it the first raider
battalion and the second raider
battalion now i knew the second raider
battalion had taken macon and that was
probably more in keeping with
the the point that i needed to make
to launch pad into my second chapter
what i didn't like was that i would have
to spend so much time with evans carlson
now if you read the book evans carlson
is
one of probably the three most peculiar
characters in the book
he's really frustrating
and you know you
if you're writing history you know the
goal is always to be objective with
characters you don't want to telegraph
to your reader that you don't like
somebody
evans carlson is a person it's hard not
to
dislike
merit
red mike edson on the other hand is
uh
he's incredible like you i mean he's
um
i mean
he was incredible before the war in
nicaragua he i mean he fought he fought
through all these little banana wars
like i i know that the marine corps
has this love affair with
chesty puller
there's no reason that
they should have any less uh affinity
for red mike edson he's everywhere uh
during world war ii um leads some of the
most daring
um uh assaults uh of the war he's at uh
tulagi the guadalcanal he's at tarawa i
mean three major
uh
battles in marine corps history he's got
a i think he had
two navy crosses a medal of honor silver
stars i mean he was he was incredible um
uh and he's got a terribly tragic and he
um
it's bizarre it is bizarre did you read
about him he yeah
he uh he he leaves the navy or he leaves
the marine corps
under protest when uh during the the
revolt of the admirals after world war
ii right before the korean war
when the army and the air force kind of
collaborated to
strip the navy in the marine corps of
funding he resigns the marine corps in
protest so he can
protest more
loudly um
he has a series of jobs and eventually
he commits suicide in his garage he
um
i don't know i mean it's one of those
you don't hear a lot of
world war ii veterans that
that made that decision um but
i mean it stands to reason you know
considering everything that we're going
through right now i mean someone who has
gone through as much
as you know read mike edson did had
suffered as many blast injuries as he no
doubt you know suffered um
i think he was probably dealing with all
the same uh same things that so many of
our friends are
yeah so
i think
that idea of resigning in protest and
what you get from it where where it ends
up is a tough thing to talk about
because once you're done
yeah
you're done
you're done and actually
um i think it was green during the
vietnam war addressed it he was like the
comment on the marine corps i i can't
forgive my memory but
you know he was getting interviewed why
didn't you you know leave because you
got mcnamara who's a jackass you got lbj
who's a total jackass
maybe it's time just to you know make
your statement hey and he said look i'll
be in the news for for 48 hours and then
that's it they'll have another guy and
i'll have no influence and that's you
know i've often talked about hackworth
doing the same thing vietnam you know he
could have been a division he could have
been a brigade commander could have been
a division commander he would have had
whatever thousands of troops underneath
him that he could have fought in a
different way but instead he
sort of
resigned in protest right um and
and yeah you know there's a there's
another um
the commanding officer of the
i want to say the lost battalion world
war one
but he was a medal of honor recipient
and he killed himself
after the
he was one of the pallbearers
at
the two for the tomb of the unknown
soldier
and
you know that happened i want to say
like 1919
was when they actually had everything
set up for the to dedicate the tomb of
the unknown soldier he was as a medal of
honor recipient he was one of the guys
that
um
that was one of those pallbearers and
then
i think it was about a year later he
booked a
sea passage from
new york to cuba or new york to florida
or something and then wrote it wrote a
note and disappeared you know killed
himself um did you read that patrick
o'donnell book
what is it called
um
i can't remember what what it's called
it was just one that i had seen it was
it looked interesting what's it about
it's about the two of the unknown
soldier oh okay no i did not read it
i'll be curious to read it it's about i
think it's about all
all the pallbearers in that uh
um
well oh there's one of them
and then well a little bit what was it
that you didn't like about carlson so
much carlson he's just
man carlson is
um
carlson
uh there were lots of characters that i
came in contact with that are other
carlsons they're characters that you
you know they they've done
and
they've done an incredible uh
amount for their country and
but you can you have the benefit of
hindsight you have the benefit of
perspective and you have to um
you have to weigh in on their legacy
um
so has carlson done more than me yeah
has carlson done more than you i mean
yeah i mean he's he fought through world
war ii like
he's uh not even close like yeah there's
nothing we can't compare you know our
contribution to somebody like carlson
he's
he's in the first
one of the first raids of the entire war
and then he fights
in successive battles
the what's important about carlson
though is that the marine corps
loses all respect for him after the make
an island raid they give him another
chance with the long patrol on
guadalcanal and he does admirable work
there but it's not enough to overshadow
uh
the the defeat and the uh the aftermath
of the make an island raid the makin
island raid
it isn't really known how
disastrous disastrous it is until 1943 a
whole year later when u.s forces retake
the island and they discover that the
the marines that they believed to have
been drowned
in the evacuation weren't drowned but
captured and killed beheaded by the
japanese
so it's sort of a
sort of a failure that kind of unfolds
over time um but when the the full scope
of the failure that make an island raid
is understood
um the marine corps never lets evans
carlson command troops ever again
now that's perfectly you know fine for
the marine corps leadership they was
there something about his personality
that his personality yeah but it was
also his politics he was uh
i think he was a borderline uh communist
he was definitely a populist um
definitely like a
a socialist populist but he was
um
by the end of the war
he's advocating for the chinese or the
not the nationals chinese the kind of
the chinese communists
eventually he he dies and disgrace
penniless because he uh he had to he
resigned from the marine corps um
i can't remember exactly what happens to
him in the aftermath but i know he has
no money and teddy roosevelt has to pay
for his funeral not teddy roosevelt um
james roosevelt
but uh some of it's his personality some
of it's just he's got he's kind of
ponderous like uh he's a bit boring like
you know stuffy like uh one of the
things that i think is most telling the
most descriptive uh episode i have or a
little vignette in the book is when one
of his junior officers comes up to him
and asks him for you know a few books uh
to read that will help him understand
you know the you know how to command or
the military art better
and
uh all the books that carlson recommends
are books that he's written
like
you've got to think a lot of yourself to
tell somebody you know if they're
looking for books
read these five that i've written so he
tried to read them and they're all
impenetrable boring books about chinese
like he gave up
well i'm very thankful right now for the
book about face by colonel david
hackworth because whenever somebody says
hey you know what's a good book for me
to read about leadership and i would say
oh yeah read about face because
otherwise i'd be pulling a carlsen and
tell him to read extreme ownership for
leadership strategy and tactics
i'm a loser
no you don't like me too i'm right up
there with carlson i didn't say that
well if it wasn't for hackworth i'd be
right up there with girls
hang on you you haven't seen the books
that carlson wrote true i had to read
them
were they just nasty they're just boring
do you remember any titles of them uh
did you read the whole thing are you
like this is ridiculous i get the idea
nelson's a dork in the beginning i did
in the beginning i had everything
collected i read books that i knew that
carlson had read just because i wanted
to think like he was thinking
he was fascinated with mao so i was
reading mao when he when i was writing
this chapter
so i got better uh with my research as i
went on but at the time like when i
wrote chapter one
uh
i had not yet stepped into an art an
archive i wrote the first draft of
chapter one just based off of uh out of
books that existed
uh from online archives i was able to
find a ton of material online uh on the
makin island raid so there i mean
uh you you pay you know 20 bucks a month
you have access to fold three and a
couple of other archives and you can
find the after action report of the uss
nautilus or the uss argonaut
um
so you know not having stepped into an
archive i was taking advantage of
everything else that was available to me
all the books that carlson had written
books that mao had written um you know
things things like that so i was i was
saturated with all this stuff this sort
of extraneous and i got better you know
in my research so chapter two was the
first time i stepped foot into an
archive and i was like oh i can do this
better
so
all right well let's get to chapter 2.
chapter 2
which is called
the sidelining of the army's amphibious
soldier scouts and the call up of the
navy's second string sailors
i think that's a pretty good title it's
pretty good it's pretty good all right
for the second string sailors that's a
nod to
you know these guys all these second
string sailors were all
members every single one of the initial
uh
navy contingent of the scouts and raider
program are all nfl veterans they've all
been
buckle he's uh not only um
a uh uh
not only was a college football star not
only an nfl star but he was uh uh
he was building his own that's what he
made his own team right he he founded
the columbus bullies uh and it would
have probably been a um a successful nfl
franchise had it not been for the start
of world war ii that is a freaking legit
name too
the columbus bullies yeah man
if i would have known see if i would
have known that tasking a bruiser might
have been task unit bullies
i guess it doesn't quite work quite as
well does it
no it seems kind of sinister yeah but
today's i guess i guess especially in
today's climate you'd be like
politically incorrect to call yourself
the bullies it's true i'm a bully he
looked like a bully if you see pictures
of him there i mean i went through you
know
like piles of pictures of buckley um
and uh
you know every every picture especially
in those world war two days he just
looks like it looks like a like a dick
looks like but that's completely
opposite of what everybody i talked to
said about actually said about the guy
he said they they all described him as
the nicest guy like he was he was just
so much fun to be around
uh was super humble um
but yeah every picture he managed to
like you know go from what i assume is a
you know pretty fun loving guy and two
you know has this big scowl on his face
and so what i i meant to go down this
path with a little bit of carlson so
carlson's personality
what was he a dick was he an arrogant
guy no he's deal he was uh how do you
end up on these failing missions was it
a lack of experience i think it was it
was a couple of things he
um
he was infatuated with the chinese in
the chinese operational system he was
the the marine corps or the the slogan
the marine corps slogan of gung-ho
came from carlson he that's his love
that's his lasting legacy to the marine
corps we understand gung-ho to me an
expression that um
you know epitomizes you know marine
corps tenacity and marine corps um
what do you freaking charge the machine
gun that's what it means uh but what up
and what it really means work together
it means work together right it's a
chinese expression it's a vague i'm not
sure if it's even accurate but he took
it from his time
on the long march with mao's gorillas
yeah it means work together
uh but i'll tell you what when we picked
apart
some of mal's work on the podcast the
thing that's crazy about miles work is
it's bait it's essentially
saying you need to utilize decentralized
command to win in military operations
and i'm like hey bro mao
you that applies to everything dude like
it you can't have decentralized
organization in order to win a war and
then centralize your government as soon
as you're done and think that you can
explain how many you know what what
every farmer in the in the country is
supposed to grow and how much we're
gonna sell whatever we're gonna sell it
for like it's crazy that they came to
that conclusion i don't understand you
know there's so many contradictions like
that in world war ii uh i mean how are
the germans who are the most you know
hierarchical government system you know
on the planet and they managed to
produce a military that was able to use
initiative decentralized command yet at
the top they're stultified they they
don't they can't accomplish anything i
mean they can't you know release the
panzers and d-day like i mean they're
but yeah at the lower level they're you
know able to do you know able to be
dynamic fluid and agile and all the rest
you know what you're when your ego
starts to get out of control you start
to think i better control everything
that's that's what happens and you could
see i mean it seemed like hitler did
that throughout world war ii he the more
he won the more he thought well i better
just control everything see it's working
i better just keep doing this and by the
end it was all on him hey we're going to
we're going to attack rush even those
generals are saying hey bro not a good
idea
no we're doing it yeah
carlson the the other thing that carlson
did was he was
he was so infatuated with the chinese
system that he was
he would eat with his men he would have
these like town hall discussions he
would uh
he essentially abolished rank except for
like in certain
aspects he
um
but when he got on the i mean when he
was um
you know on the actual macon island raid
you can see a clear
um misunderstanding of what the mission
was
which told me i mean you're
that is conveying to you he doesn't know
what his mission objective is he hasn't
thought through he spent two weeks
sitting on a submarine you know
driving across the pacific under you
know completely miserable conditions you
know sweating
you know through his you know yeah like
and he finally gets there i was on
modern day subs that had ac and they
were super clean and you're not worried
about getting depth charges dropped on
your freaking head imagine a two week
transit no i can't god two little fumes
all up in there
and he gets there they get on the island
and they look around and there's you
know there's nothing really to raid i
mean just the fact that they landed
there the fact that they were able to
assault a japanese position and win
mission accomplished get off the island
there's nothing else that you have to do
here there's no intelligence that you're
really going to gather but he
he just he's paralyzed which just you
know like i said it conveys that he
doesn't know what he's doing he doesn't
really know what the the purpose of this
mission is he hasn't connected you know
the uh navy's planner's vision
you know to their actions on on that
island
and then you're comparing that to buck
lou who was like a good guy a nice guy
even though he looked like a bully
um
so would you wait you said this is when
you started going into the archives for
the first time was chapter two chapter
two yeah so i because you didn't spend
enough freaking time invested in in
research just on just on online reading
carlson's books
so you wanted more yeah you're a glutton
i don't know i mean if i had known
so there were two things that i got from
chapter one writing that i was like
i was encouraged because i felt like i
was a good researcher i'd put you know a
a compelling chapter together um were
you a sniper no
i was a uh calm guy and a breacher
jtac type yeah i was a calm guy too
but i'm just thinking from a patient's
perspective yeah i'm really antsy it's i
finally yeah i i don't know what the the
disconnect is because i find myself like
in ever whenever i'm being instructed
now or like i find myself like i get
real like i i can't i can't listen to
this guy
i gotta get out of here i'll find myself
just leaving i would have thought you
would have gone down the sniper because
you have this you know super anyone
that's you know going into archives and
reading carlson's
third book on whatever communist
leadership from 1932.
now i didn't want to read it like i
remember looking at that book and just
kind of like hanging my head like i
gotta read another one of these things
i don't know what i don't know why i was
compelled to do it i was though and i
wanted i just wanted to get it right i
wanted to i wanted to have a good idea
of who this guy was and i also didn't
have the benefit of reading carlson's
you know letters like i did with other
people you know say like a buckle or a
house is that because carlson didn't
have letters no he has them i just
didn't go to the archive oh so now you
get to the archives yeah so that's and
now you're starting to find real i'm
finding real documents i'm finding like
i'm getting i know buckley i know how
from because i've i'm i'm reading their
letters i'm reading like um i'm reading
you know the letters of the the the
folks that um you know created the
scouts and raiders like pedicord
and uh you know not just you know
reading their letters but i'm talking to
family members talking to people that
actually knew them i'm getting a real
sense of who they are it completely
changed how i researched but it it also
told me one thing i was not going to be
able to you know write this book from my
basement which was terrifying i was
gonna have to go places i was gonna have
to you know hunt for stuff and it was
terrifying in the beginning talk to
people talk to people the worst
that that did become like you know the
one nice thing about uh you know writing
a book about world war ii is
um
you don't have anybody arguing with what
you're going to write about them you
know they don't exist they're not
because they're around anymore yeah when
you get to vietnam
i'll tell you i'll tell you a story
later in the podcast there's people who
are still alive that i wrote about that
don't like what was written about them
ouch but you know you
you insulate yourself from you know the
the criticism by your due diligence you
make sure that you get it right if you
don't and shame on you
but in chapter have you had to retract
anything no there's nothing that i've
ever attracted nothing there's nothing
that i would i've communicated with with
folks
you know after
um
and
the
uh
one case uh he the the person i wrote
about he had just passed away his family
read about uh what i wrote about them
it's nothing you know
particularly damning or anything like
that but they weren't
they weren't
thrilled to hear that their dad had um
you know
not
completely succeeded in vietnam and had
kind of run off with a nurse and saigon
um
so what i said to them is you know they
they
they were i think the the note that they
sent me said you know we were
disappointed to learn about you know
what you perceive as our dad's failure
in vietnam and i responded i don't think
your dad was a failure absolutely not he
prepared seal team one for war
he failed in this one
narrow narrow context
and that context being
did he advance or
did he advance naval special warfare
toward you know what they ultimately
became land focused commando raiders i
and in that context no he didn't and
another he did he was a success
but
um
you know i i told him i you know even
though
uh
he failed in that you know
uh particular moment
ever lots of people were failing in that
particular moment nobody really
understood what you know what they were
getting their hands into yeah it's real
easy to look back with hindsight
absolutely
obviously we should have done this
instead of that it's like very easy to
look back and say that you know right
and so i ultimately told him i was like
i'm i'm proud to call him my teammate i
mean i i look at his legacy and you know
i i see you know mistakes that i made
like i'm not perfect either and nobody
is
so anyway so so we get the second string
sailors these are
the the tuna fish right yeah he's the
tuna fish
these are all guys that have gotten kind
of roped into the u.s navy um
kind of accidentally like buckle he
joins the navy because the army and the
marine corps won't take him because he's
humongous
i mean he's too big he tries to
volunteer for the paratroopers he's too
big
and
the the quote uh from from his oral
history is that the recruiter told him
that the uh the army could take two
instead of him based on just his weight
which is completely accurate and buckley
isn't even the biggest one big john
tripson um
when you see pictures of buckle and
trips and next to each other trypsin is
a head taller than buckler how tall you
think trypsin was i am
six seven probably i mean he's massive
he's a mountain of a man he's six seven
and he's just big yeah
he's just a big we had this conversation
on the last podcast because
imagine being six seven like 260 270 in
1940 right i mean no one's even lifting
bro no nobody's lifting these guys are
just jacked through nature through
football they're playing a lot of
football like
and halperin who i wrote about he's the
smallest one
halperin was the you know he's the
jewish guy that you know went to play
for notre dame
and uh i think he was
like 62 225 something like that and he's
the smallest the smallest of the tuna
fish yeah so all these guys end up in
the navy
which
and they're thinking hey we're going to
figure something out because we're
jacked we're physical we're kind of
beasts yeah they they pull them in to be
like calisthenics yeah let's say that
and that's what they get pulled they
think that that's what they're going to
do they think they're you know joining
to go you know do this like you know
whatever commando program and they get
you know
roped into you know gene tunney gene
tony is you know he's a famous character
um himself he's the uh
he's the two-time
um boxing champion yeah he beat uh
help me out joe lewis no not joe lewis
um
this is terrible because i wrote
i wrote two whole pages about tony's
fight in
philadelphia uh
with um
i can't think of it uh i know that i
know that you wrote about the fact that
he like trained he was the first person
to train yeah he's the guy that like
yeah that that was going through
physical training in order to get good
and
he was able to
he only fought like three times though
yeah
and two of those were championship
fights jack dempsey jack dempsey that's
right
so uh all right so now we got these guys
so yeah so they
they're they're in uh gene tony's regime
of physical fitness instructors they're
kind of getting uh they're taking navy
recruits they're they're they're
training them they're putting them
through um you know little little pt
sessions like uh
um
they're doing log pts they're doing like
little uh like group activities the
stuff that you know uh either gene tony
had pulled from the marine corps or uh
that uh they had kind of um developed
along the way themselves
which
you know
that's going to plant a seed for later
when you know the scouts and raiders
conditioning curriculum gets compressed
by draper kaufman
but they all volunteer for this this
commando program they don't really know
what it is
but then they get hoodwinked again from
you know tony's regime
to being landing craft skippers for army
commandos the you know the raider
section of the scouts and raider program
um
that would piss me off so bad wouldn't
it oh man they find themselves out there
and they're like all right you guys are
going to be in charge of the boats
i would be angry what's the character
you got some guy named whitsleeben
oh somebody that you caught you were
telling me about this guy what's this
guy uh slavin so when i wrote the uh
initial draft of this chapter i the the
thing that i i felt like i had to convey
was that uh
um
the the senior commanders in world war
ii they had uh they had a serious
problem uh when it came to uh amphibious
warfare one they didn't have landing
craft uh but two even if they did have
landing crew a bit of a problem they
didn't know
uh the army's commanders they didn't
know how to put troops ashore and there
were
uh there were logistics problems they
they knew that they would need to even
if they uh were able to land um men even
if they were able to put landing craft
on beaches uh they needed to put um men
on beaches in which there were beach
exits so
exits so you could drive vehicles off
the beach i mean if you land on a beach
that has you know cliff faces and you
can't drive off the beach then
what good is it that you've you know had
all these landing crafts you have to
have
guys that can find
beaches
good beaches
and then
alert the army uh to where those beaches
are so you know it can
bring an entire landing force ashore
the army has completely
um in the interwar period from world war
one to world war ii they've done almost
nothing uh when it comes to the
development of amphibious doctrine
nothing showcased
the threat of all of that more
than
the terrible disaster at dieppe which
happens in august of 1942 that's the
first time
the allies attempt to land um troops on
an enemy beach
or a a nazi-controlled enemy beach now
the proponents of troops in the battle
are canadians there's a decent amount of
british commandos
there's a handful of american of army
rangers
they go ashore
most of the canadians are killed or
captured
and part of the reason that this raid or
this assault or this attempted you know
dress rehearsal of d-day fails is
because they don't have a good
assessment of
um what the beach exits were like they
didn't know how uh when they got ashore
the tanks either
they weren't able to get off the beach
because the sand was too
too loose they couldn't their their
treads um buried up to the hubs they
couldn't get out they couldn't get off
the beach the tanks that or the tanks
and the vehicles that were able to get
off the beach they ran into tank traps
almost immediately
so
um the idea was you know create you know
writing this whole chapter on you know
the upgrade was just you know
a way for me to talk about uh you know
all the imperatives that a uh a scout
and raider force would need to
um
solve yeah
bring to the table yeah for the for the
mission right you needed to find a beach
you know that you could land on you know
the sand is dense enough uh that had
beach exits uh and that you could you
know signal the rest of the fleet for
i cut it all
gone all of it was gone and with laven
was one of those characters he was one
of the architects of uh you know
hitler's initial push to fortify um the
the atlantic wall
i don't know why i put vitslaven on my
nose but he was he was a character that
i got sucked into because he was one of
those guys that he hated hitler
and yet he still did everything he could
to you know fortify the coast he was
ultimately one of those guys that
participated in the july 20th plot to
kill hitler and he ended up getting
executed by dangling from a meat hook
anyway
it's a little bit of a rabbit hole isn't
it isn't it
every one of these freaking characters
is like i know it's a lot i mean it's a
lot but you know all these things are
just you know they're
they're what what's the what's the
problem with buckley
the problem with buckle is he's
everywhere
meaning what he's too he's moving around
too much no trying to do too much what
no no no he like the pro the pro the
buckley presents a problem presented a
problem for uh for a writer not for
anybody else buckles
incredible
and i uh i wrote i wrote you know
sections about buklu in chapter two i
wrote sections about buckley in chapter
four sections about buckley in chapter
six a section i mean a whole chapter
about him on uh
um
in the buckley report and then again uh
he he comes on the stage in
in my chapters on vietnam and he's the
commander of naval operational support
group he's everywhere he is the
indispensable person in the history of
naval special warfare
what was uh
the problem that i ran into is
that
if i had talked about him a little bit
here and i talked about him a little bit
here and then a little bit there
i was kind of wasting ammo on him i was
gonna let her i was gonna you know i was
gonna force a reader to kind of
discover
um
uh all of them buckles relevance you
know instead of like compressing buckle
into that final uh um chapter and you
know on the buckler report and really
you know instead of you know spreading
spreading out your tanks you know
consolidating into one punch so the
reader finally gets a sense of how
important this person is i just didn't
want to waste buckloo you know
throughout the book i wanted to you know
collect him on one thing but it took me
you know almost until the book was
entirely written and then i had to go
back through the book and i cut buckle
cut buckle cut buckles so i could you
know
yeah because otherwise you're kind of
giving away the story because because
buckley
doesn't become but you're not he wasn't
buckle out of the gate i mean he was a
stud sure it wasn't like phil h buckley
right which is what the where seal
training takes place is called the phil
h buckley center for navy special
warfare right our schoolhouse is named
after this guy but he didn't come out of
the gate that way he came out of the
gate as
a guy and he never kind of shines in the
way that other characters did so i was
always frustrated because i knew that i
had to talk about buckle and i knew the
buck was so important but he never you
know he's not the first guy ashore like
halpern is he's not uh
he's not the the ground force commander
in china like halpern is um but he's
there he's always there like all the you
know like some some other characters too
so but i i just didn't want to lose the
was he was he younger is that why he was
still around when vietnam gets comes
into play they were all about the same
age uh i think he was younger than
halperin however was the old man of the
group happened was 34. i think he was 34
when he enlisted as a seaman right
alfred was
and he was a notre dame graduate and a
nfl player and all this other crazy
stuff nfl player he was running his
dad's uh commercial light company in
chicago he was developing a clothing
store i mean he was kind of like he was
kind of the jocko
like he kind
[Music]
he was married like he and he and he was
a professional you know sailboat racer
he was a competitive sailboat racer on
lake michigan i don't know if you
remember in the
in his epitaph that i write in the book
he was
halperin was uh he was in the 1960s
olympics uh for sailing what that was a
bronze medal what a freaking stud yeah
he's incredible and he was 34 when he so
he must have been old in 1960
he's he's old and you in the pictures of
him must be like 55 60 years old in the
olympics he's the oldest man that was
competing at that time
but by then
uh halperin has developed i mean
halperin is
you know he's more than he's got he's
friends with uh he's friends with
sinatra he knows everybody like he's
running you know he he founded l.l bean
like he's by that point in his life i
mean he's wait buck halperin founded l.l
bean yeah explain that to me a little
bit that's as much as i know i know he
was one of the founders finally i got to
the end of one of your rabbit holes you
you didn't have the freaking wherewithal
to dig in full detail development well
maybe if you know if it wasn't for the
fact that i have a factory up in maine
where we produce stuff near l.l bean
maybe that's a little bit of an
important deal we could have known a
little bit more about the frogman
history of llv well i'll give him some
props i'll get to the bottom of that one
for you
i think he sold his shares
uh but yeah buckley
he doesn't he doesn't quite you know
outshine you know halpin and or other
other guys and all these other episodes
so but he does you know like he finally
takes center stage you know during the
buckley report and his whole biography
is compressed into that into that report
but that's
getting ahead of the story
all right
we roll into chapter three and this was
um
i mean it's a rough one to read uh i was
listening to and and re-reading it i was
listening to the podcast we did on it
man this is a freaking hard one to read
because
it's um
well the name of the chapter is the us
army's first commandos and the raid that
wasn't
so this is that's not about this one of
your more abbreviated titles so so we
give you credit for that
uh
i don't know why you're laughing
well you know echo has a new doesn't
even say anything i try and keep it i
try and keep it tight echo's not even
talking so once you mentioned it i can't
unsee it
oh he's just getting warmed up man i'm
telling you he's going off from here
it's kind of like when theo vaughn said
he looked at you halfway through the
podcast and says like what about you
your name is echo you haven't said
anything yet
the first guy named echo you sure don't
say much yeah there you go that was a
good observant uh situation
this was a rough one because
well i guess because of because of what
happened with the rangers right in the
beginning
what was what was it like writing this
chapter
um
this is a
this was the fifth chapter i wrote so i
felt like i was i was further along i
was better uh than um i was with some of
the earlier chapters i don't i don't
know if that accounts for
you know why i think that the chapter
has such a great arc to it but i or it's
just because the
you know the history itself has such a
you know
such
a tragic arc um
it was hard to write this in the sense
that i was
i always assumed that i'd be rooting for
the navy like throughout the book
rooting for
you know the the navy chapters and then
i'd get to an army or marine corps
chapter and i'd be like uh see i told
you so like uh i knew i you know i knew
that you guys were gonna you know screw
up and there'd be an opportunity for the
navy i found the opposite to be true or
not maybe not the opposite but i found
myself
you know um
uh
you know just
you know empathizing with these guys so
much like there were
i mean this
the ranger contribution um
uh in world war ii is
it's remarkable
uh the contribution of guys like darby
remarkable i mean
um
and to have to write about darby
critically um
that wasn't easy to do i had to
um
it was the first time that i had to
write about somebody who you know i knew
to be you know a legitimate american
hero
um
and and write about them you know in a
in a light that's not flattering and i'm
not sure that anybody's ever done that
before i'd read a lot of books about
darby and every single one of them they
you know
his they burnished his legacy they they
consider him you know to be one of the
the the founders or one of the
the most important uh you know greatest
contributors to american special
operations history and that's true
but there's also this other truth
that darby should have known better
and he didn't um and i don't know why i
mean i i thought
i spent a lot of time thinking about it
like
nobody in the us army knew better than
darby what a raid was
and how a raid could be successful
and
what elements would have to be put
together for that raid to fail
and that raid i mean there's so many uh
you know kind of warning bells about the
raid on cisterna that should have
alerted darby uh and the rest of the
chain of command that this was this was
a disaster waiting to happen and yet you
know nobody threw the brakes on
this is one of the ones where you do a
little psychological kind of profiling
of darby um i actually wanted to read
this section part of it i read on the
last one but it's worth reading again
um
because part of it i didn't read in the
last one black-haired blue-eyed wide
mouth as a duck darby had a ruddy face
divided into equal parts forehead and
chin
his left cheek bore a mysterious
brilliant red scar not particularly
muscularly muscular
he nevertheless affected chest out
shoulders back posture in which his arms
always seemed cocked to the rear as if
never more than a moment away from
snapping to attention son of a printer
and a musician the second child between
two sisters he grew up scouting the
arkansas woods and playing the saxophone
when in high school his older sister
died in texas he married then divorced
in spite of disappointment and tragedy
his attitude remained just as ever been
good humored and irresponsible or sorry
irrepressible
in personality just like in posture he
was direct forceful and never
vacillating
had the military gene not dominated and
driven him to a life of soldiering he
would have been been a salesman
he is the ideal commando leader wrote
colonel vaughn at the end of the course
he possesses the energy keenness and
personality which produces the best out
of those under his command
graduated from west point in 1933 at the
apex of the bell curve ranked 177 out of
a class of 346 he was originally
assigned as a field artillery officer
like all soldiers who graduated then and
with that assignment
he embarked on an eight-year career
punctuated by the peacetime artillery
corps elements boredom and horse manure
in 1941 he was one of the few soldiers
who attended the joint army marine corps
amphibious exercises in puerto rico
disappointed at not snagging a combat
command in the wake of the pearl harbor
attacks in mid-january 1942 he was made
assistant to major general russell p
hartl
commander of the 34th infantry and
assigned to northern ireland the staging
area for a theater of operation still
two years in the future
anxious to get into the war when
assigned to escort general truscott on
his base tour and ranger recruitment
drive darby made the most of it truscott
duly rewarded darby's professionalism
and interest with an offer to command
the first ranger battalion
few offers have been accepted so
enthusiastically at first glance darby's
rangers viewed him as a
pencil pushing aid to camp and why not
he was after all little more than a
peacetime artillery officer not even an
infantryman
this perception died a quick death
throughout their training
darby slung a standard m1 over his
shoulder and rotated between companies
marching climbing shooting doing
whatever the men were doing and doing it
better after an intelligence officer
from headquarters briefed the rangers on
the allied procedures for surrendering
to the enemy darby bristled and took the
floor this formation this information
you have just heard is all very well for
those troops who are going to be
captured but that is not for rangers
if there's any any capturing to be done
he continued it is the rangers who will
do it within two months of training
together the men were reverently calling
him el darbo
by the end he would defy comparison an
army staff officer waiting ashore
at sorrento in 1943 in 1943 would find a
man wearing a ranger patch and ask where
he might find darby smirking the ranger
would reply you'll never find him this
far back
if the ideal army officer was equal
parts confidence bravery
energy and obedience
darby was all these things
but perhaps too much the last
and that that sentence stuck with me um
you know from a leadership perspective
of course
because it's about balance right and you
do need to be obedient but at the same
time
if you're too obedient
you're
[Music]
yeah
you're too obedient right there's a
famous quote um by one of
frederick the great's generals uh he
says to a young
officer uh
the the king gave you a commission so
you uh because he uh assumed that you
would know when to break orders
um
and
that's all part of initiative i mean
that's all like
if there was one
trait that i
sort of settled on as being the reason
that the
um
the navy
seemed to be ahead of the game or at
least uh ahead of its peers when it came
to the creation of special operations
units it was because the navy had this
culture of latitude and this
decentralized command and lat and uh
initiative
that enabled
subordinates
to feel like they had the flexibility to
make decisions on the fly or
adjust to the realities
that they were you know facing whereas
somebody like
um
somebody like darby
um darby is in the u.s army and one
thing that i wrote is you know the the
chain of command in the us army
has never been
it's never been de-linked it's only been
progressively thickened over time and
you see that
not just in not just today but you can
kind of see it happen uh gradually and i
would see it you know a little bit in
world war ii and i kind of got my first
sense of it here uh
reading and writing about the rangers
but i also saw it you know in my korean
war chapters i would come across you
know a an army general like uh
edwin walker who he's um
flying above his troops above his
soldiers um in a little spotter plane
with a bullhorn telling individual units
which one you know which one to move
like
i mean
in some sense that you know that says to
you the reader you you know uh i mean
what a cool what a cool general that
he's you know willing to you know put
himself out there but at the same time
like that's also like awful that's
taking all the initiative away from your
guys and you're you know you're you're
not only telling them where they should
advance but you're also telling them
that they don't have the authority to to
retreat either if they need to or to you
know gain a tactical advantage by
maneuver centralized command at its
worst right there absolutely
and the last time we we you were on we
talked about the fact that hey when
you're in the navy you know throughout
history and you you know if ben's in
charge of this ship you're gonna go sail
away from me as the admiral
i can't talk to you anymore like you're
you've got the mission you're gonna do
it to the best of your ability the other
thing that's interesting about this is
sometimes the ocean
is going to dictate what you're going to
do like there are certain times where
you cannot
you cannot proceed you cannot continue
the ocean is going to stop you you know
you can get some really really extreme
examples where weather could inhibit you
on land from making the type of progress
you want to make but you right a river
swollen right a river swollen but those
are extreme examples right the out in
the ocean
that's kind of a regular thing you know
there's giant sea states that come
through it's it's so so
you have to have some more ability to
adapt because you are go
look if you're in a sailboat
the wind's not blowing you're not going
anywhere right that's what's happening
you can't maneuver to the north because
the direction of the wind or the
direction of the sea state you can't do
it it's not going to happen so you have
to have some level of flexibility
whereas
more so
on the ground you can power through a
lot of
weather events and again i'm going back
to you know times before radios and
before before motors where
you're just going to make this happen
so
it seems like yeah unfortunately um that
darby was a little heavy on the
obedience
and
it's not always a positive thing
no i mean i
um
and not just on um not just on obedience
but on uh um
prerogatives that's not the right word
either but protocol i would say so he
gets uh one of the one of the shocking
um
things that i saw when he was putting
the the cisterna raid together was he uh
put in charge of the entire assault
element a uh an officer who'd never been
with the rangers
just because he was in the rank yeah
just because he
uh he had a date of rank um
uh you know the preceded you know the
the rangers uh that he'd been working
with
since they'd been training together in
scotland these were rangers that knew
what being a ranger was they
these guys have been trained by the
british commandos they knew what a raid
was they knew the you know how a raid
would succeed and how it would fail and
within the and instead of you know
putting one of his
you know one of his rangers uh that he
knew from scotland in charge he selected
the guy
who'd never been a ranger not and he's
not a bad leader he's an excellent
leader and he acquits himself you know
incredibly during the battle but he also
doesn't know um as as daylight's um
creeping up on these guys and they
have a sense of
we are in the middle of a german
division
there is we can't do this we can't
accomplish this he does not have the
confidence to say guys we're turning
around
so
um
speaking of british commandos uh i know
one of the one of the people that you
had to
kind of cut
was mountbatten
lord louis mountbatten this dude is like
the british of all british right
he is but he's not like the one thing
that i thought was
uh interesting about mountbatten is um
they're germans the mountbatten family
they're they're germans his his uh
father i believe it's his father he uh
becomes the first lord of the admiralty
but he's born in germany he serves in
the german navy um he doesn't uh
emigrate to uh england or to the united
kingdom until he's a bit older and then
he rises up through the ranks of the
british navy becomes the first lord um
but mount batten
uh so prince philip
prince philip who just passed away he
was a mountbatten so lord louis
mountbatten was his uncle
jack yeah so mountbatten
um
i mean he's a fascinating character he's
he by the time he's put in charge of
combined operations headquarters or the
the entity that uh commands all british
commandos uh he's been i think he's been
shot out from under two ships or he's
had two ships that were sunk um
um
you know we you that's the second time
you've made that statement about hey
this guy had two ships shot out from
under him yeah
and it sounds really cool right now
right yeah like damn you know cause
we're like you know
we think that's kind of cool but i
wonder if there's any negative
if someone's looking like dude this
guy's lost two ships bro what's wrong
with you yeah right
i wonder
i didn't think about well he kept
getting promoted yeah he had the
political connections he's really young
he's really dynamic he's one of the few
people that
is able to not uh
dominate churchill but he's able to like
churchill thinks he's just
i mean he's this cavalier um and so he
so he he's the one that grew up in
germany
that's his dad
that's his dad yeah louis mountbatten he
grows up he's as british as uh
i don't know
he's british he's british and he seems
to have like all the stereotypical kind
of british personality absolutely yeah
he's he
acts british
yes he's the
um
he's uh
i mean he's he's playing polo and
writing books on polo and stuff like
this i mean this is it man
he's hanging out with a king and queen
he's got a cigarette holder i mean he's
he's british he's the he's the
quintessential british but the commandos
themselves
who we who we kind of
who we throw in with the sort of who who
who played their biggest role in in
creating creating the british commandos
is that is that clark
uh yeah dudley clark he's the guy who
initially comes up with the idea he's
another weirdo um really fun to learn
about really fun to write he's um he was
a he was a british army officer he'd
grown up i believe in palestine
he had
seen um
not only he'd seen
british raiders during the first world
war it kind of experienced what some of
that was like i think he
he was friendly with ward wingate he was
um
oh yeah one of one of the things
one of the ways that he got the idea for
british commandos was he was infatuated
with napoleonic war history and
not he was a real student of
wellington's peninsula peninsular wars
and all of the partisans that wellington
had hired and uh
and sent against the the french forces
uh so he
when um after the disaster at dunkirk
you know
dudley clark who's a bit you know a bit
of an oddball in the military uh
hierarchy i think his hobby is he's a uh
he's an amateur actor but he puts a
little paper together and he sends it up
to churchill and it's a the paper is
essentially
create special troops uh that are
capable at sea uh and send them on all
these little um uh raids against the the
coastline spread out german defenses not
you know dissimilar from what the navy
was trying to do in the central pacific
um churchill
uh
it's
churchill's you know completely
infatuated with any idea that uh his
generals do not like and this is one of
them he
um
he thinks this is a great idea not just
because you know this is going to spread
german defenses out but you know more
importantly than that it's going to
energize the british people the british
people have just suffered this this
terrible
you know
defeat at dunkirk they need a win they
need a series of wins
so
yeah
he agrees to it he
pushes the entire
british establishment to create these
commandos
what he does not expect and what his
generals don't expect as that these
raids start being successful
um so successful that uh they they want
to develop more of them and
um so the
uh by
night by the end of or by 1942 there's
not just british commandos at this point
there's canadian commandos there's
french commandos and they're all sort of
operating under this uh the cohq
um
have you ever read the book rogue heroes
it's a book about the british sas um no
north africa it follows them all through
the war but boy if you want a
a book that is kind of outside of you
know the american special operations
experience um
that is that's the one it's it's
interesting because you know uh it's
even
i would say it's uh the the sas
experience the sas and the sba sbs
experience uh during world war ii
establishes a
um a type of commando
that we are not familiar with like and
it establishes a legacy of expectations
that you know we don't really have like
our we have sort of a no fail
expectations on our commando operations
the sas the sbs
they were willing to just try stuff
and if they lost an entire team well
that's the price of doing business i
mean and i think they kind of carry that
cavalierness through today like i think
i mean if you've ever worked with sis or
sbs i'm sure you have i have yeah i mean
i don't know if you noticed that in them
i certainly noticed it when we worked
with the sbs these guys are you know
maybe not uh
as
i wouldn't say they're not they're less
well trained but they are willing to
they have an expectation of uh risk
uh
that i was not familiar with and i think
they pull that directly from this
experience in world war ii
check what else was it that made dudley
clark an oddball
i mean the dude's an actor i mean we
know echo isn't a bit of an actor i
don't think he's odd
really
was there some other was there some
other uh thing that dragged you into
this or or that you started getting the
feeling this guy's a little strange yeah
he leads the first commando raid
um
and it's a completely i mean
so he has this idea you know not much
different than carlson you know to come
up with these you know commandos but and
and like carlson he leads one of the
first grades and like carlson he's
completely unsuited to do it like i mean
he's not a
he's not an operational commander he's a
thinker um i think he kind of he
suspects that but he's willing to you
know put himself on the line to prove
you know his his ideas
um he ends up going through the war and
coming up with uh
he he ends up being um
a really um
capable spy not spymaster but like
deception officer he's able to convince
uh the germans at you know different
points during the war that we're about
to attack in uh in this in this spot
which forces the germans to move troops
to an area
but he leads that first commando raid
and they don't really rate anything i
think they stumble across two german
bicyclists they kill both of them they
forget to search them they don't know
what they were even guarding and then on
his on his particular raid
they one of the one of the guys
accidentally ejects a magazine onto a
beach right when
there's an approaching german patrol the
germans counter-ambush them and they
have to race into the the water to get
back to their boats when they get back
to their boats dudley clark realizes
that his ears but almost been shot off
and a sailor has to stitch it back in
place for the transit back to
back to england
damn
yeah
getting the ears stitched back on by a
by a little by a petty officer even like
in like a freaking zodiac or something
yeah and the position is so badly
planned when they get when they finally
get back uh to the coast back to they
they didn't have any deconfliction they
get stopped by british uh shore about
patrol boats uh thinking that they're a
german uh boat you know trying to send
raiders ashore um and when the and when
the um
the coast guard comes aboard their their
vessel uh all the british commandos are
drunk
so not only did they get shot off the
beach they drank the entire boat slicker
supply
there you go how about the devil's
brigade how does that play into this uh
whole scene the devil's brigader um
they were just one they were one of
those uh units that i was really
interested in i really i was almost
trying like looking for an excuse to to
write about them they were
um they were a unit that uh was a it was
a joint um
canadian an american uh unit and it was
the kind of the brainchild of
mountbatten
marshall had buy-in
it was supposed to be a unit that they
dropped into norway on uh like
snowmobiles or snow tractors
that would lead raids ultimately became
a pretty adequate um
semi-commando force
it was an air sort of sort of ranger
sort of airborne
um and robert fredericks became the
commander of it he was as
as interesting as darby uh you know it
was
had you know as equally a storied career
i think he was uh wounded something like
nine times uh during the course of the
war
um
and what was the how come the devil's
brigade didn't
sustain
well i mean the army special forces when
they are um when they are claiming uh
their um their forefathers they always
point to the devil's brigade i don't
really i don't really see a connection
between uh army special forces and the
devil's projects
except for the fact that these guys are
in the army well they're in the army and
they're and they're airborne qualified
check so but they're not leading
partisans or anything like that they're
shock troops
they're more like rangers then they're
more like rangers just like meryl's
marauders merrill's marauders are you
know when i set out to write a chapter
on the rangers and to talk about uh how
the rangers opened a gap for the navy to
fill
i didn't think that i'd be covering
darby other people had covered darby
before and i was like i kind of want to
avoid that i'd rather focus on you know
a a a ranger legacy that has you know
that's less well-known and my idea
initially was to cover the 5307 which is
merrell's marauders and burma i really
wanted to um uh instead of cisterna
cover the the battle of michikina which
is a an isolated uh hilltop in burma
that the meryles marauders sees and
there's some you know pretty interesting
characters merrell uh he's a he's
another oddball i think he by that point
in the war he's been removed because
he's already had two heart attacks in
burma
he stayed in the field and it was
another excuse for you know to talk
about stillwell still was another
character that i've always you know kind
of had a soft spot in my heart for but
they just didn't fit because you know
the reason that i had to cover cisterna
the reason that that i had to talk about
cisterna as opposed to point to hawk or
magekina or another one of these
really important ranger battles is
because cisterna is the one
that leaves its impression on the army
uh
hierarchy on the chain of command
even when you have a success as
incredible as point to hawk even when
you have a success as incredible as
kabata tuan
and the rescue of all those pows it
doesn't leave its legacy or it doesn't
leave an impression on the army chain of
command like cisterna does so sterna
clouds an entire generation of hostility
of regular conventional army leaders to
the concept of elite commandos
if that makes sense
yeah that's definitely that that section
of the book um and again i read it on
the last the last time we were together
on this podcast um it's just it's it's
it's very different it's still difficult
to even read and and what's incredible
about it is it's it's the notes
from the radial room these are these are
transcripts of what was actually said
between darby
and his front line leadership who are
being overrun and slaughtered and you
can
you can read exactly what they were
saying to each other it's um yeah
another just incredible a lot of that a
lot of that's taken from um
you know like like you said the
transcripts which i that's one of the
few times that i was at an archive going
through it uh going through a document
and not just you know quickly taking up
a photo and moving on that was one of
those times where i was like
i was trying i mean i knew what happened
and i'm
i was reading it like it was a novel
like and i was you know tensing up like
you know knowing what each page that
each page was going to get worse and
worse and worse and that i was
i was watching this unfold in an archive
you know 80 years after the fact but it
was you know it was every bit as real to
me well maybe not every bit is real but
you know you're
these are you know fellow fellow
americans you're doing the absolute best
they could for their country for each
other and and you know the guy on the
other end of the radio was watching his
friends die around him
and then before we move to chapter four
what about what about charles
schumstrom
what's that guy's deal he got cut
completely out of the book is that right
yeah sort of i mean he got um
so he
he's responsible for writing the
shuntstrom report which is the uh it was
the report written
um only um
well if i do the math right probably a
month after cisterna so he's one of um
he's one of the guys that was captured
in the in the in the final moments of
the the raid he was um he had been with
darby
all the way through uh the the rangers
experience so he'd been one of the
handful of rangers trained by the
british commandos and acne carries
scotland um fought through north africa
fought through sicily uh fought through
uh italy the winter line uh and then
he's one of the
officers uh captured he's one he's the
officer who's driving darby uh in jayla
when darby is in the back uh with a 50
cal or with the uh the recoilless rifle
and destroys the italian tank that turns
darby from darby into darby the legend
so he's with darby uh throughout you
know the uh everything he's he's as
you know
he's as incredible or as
anyway he
he's captured
at cisterna
escapes two weeks later
makes it back to friendly lines uh and
from from his escape he's able to write
this report of what actually happened
he's one of the few guys that got out
and he drafts this
i can't remember the 10-page report so a
lot of what's in those final pages uh is
is drawn from the shunstrom report now
he has a uh a really tragic end to his
life he um i can't remember how he
passes away i think he's dead within 10
years though of of this event he
after world war ii he
i think he goes to southern california
he tries to be an actor doesn't work out
and then he
you know turns to drink
and a series of bad decisions leads to a
series of worse decisions and i think he
starts robbing banks
he's one of those guys that you know he
just isn't able to reintegrate into
society he's been a ranger officer one
of the you know guys in charge and here
he is he's not able to you know um
uh
reintegrate into you know polite society
and he ultimately i can't remember how
he dies but i think it's some
combination of alcohol and
um
some combination of alcohol robin banks
guns just getting after it
you know this
is pretty good you got to kind of ask
yourself
and i had a conversation with someone
the other day about you know that just
like modern times and all this
who's gonna fight the wars
yeah right who is going to
put freaking
black paint on their face
and pick up a weapon and crawl across
the beach
and start killing enemy like that's a
certain type of human being right that's
the type of human being that may not
correctly reintegrate into society this
dude might end up robbing banks when he
gets back
it's the martin watson problem yeah it's
the martin watson problem which we'll
get to
but but we do have to think about that
and and
when you have guys you know we we talked
about obedience
as a characteristic being look it is it
good to have some obedience yes it is
and was darby maybe too far on the
spectrum of being too obedient yes but
then you get some other guys that are on
the other end of the spectrum that you
want you want to have someone that's
going to be like hey i don't care what
you tell me to do i'm going to go attack
this machine gun nest get out of my way
you want to have some guys like that
they're hard to control
but if you get rid of these guys if you
get rid of the charles shumstroms and
the watsons you get rid of those guys
your military is not going to be able to
function in my opinion it's not going to
be able to win i said okay yep you're
right it's not it's going to be able to
function probably going to be able to
function very effectively in a peacetime
environment
so my question you've commanded these
guys
how how i mean what what's the answer
how do you how do you you know take the
strengths of a of a sunstrom or a watson
but how do you make sure that they don't
go off the rails yeah what you have to
do is you have to put put the
put the guard rails in place and you
have to and it's not here's the
interesting thing about this this isn't
that hard
this isn't where you've got to be
constantly monitoring every single thing
that they do you have a good
relationship with your guys
then when you say hey listen here's the
line we're not crossing it guys go yep
roger that and they know you're not
playing around they you haven't
you haven't uh uh shown them where hey
you know jacko says this but he doesn't
really mean that no it's like when i say
something this is what i mean and this
is what we're gonna do this is what
we're not gonna do
and and look i mean i had
guys that were definitely
actually i want to have guys just like i
just said i want to have guys they're
going to say hey if i can get if i get
the chance to do this
in a high progressive way i'm going to
do it you give me a chance to kill the
enemy i'm going to do it that's what i'm
going to do that's what i'm here for
that's why that's why i was born dude
tony of freddie you know tony of freddie
tony was a platoon chief in charlie
platoon tasking a bruiser i if
he would do anything to be able to go
out and kill the enemy and he would also
never cross the line of like oh okay
hey we're not doing that cool that's
then that's the line
and that's exactly what you want
um
and and what so so the question that you
posed to me how do you do it what you do
is you have a good relationship with the
guys you explain to them what we can do
what we can't do and then you explain
why we can't do it
and there was um
uh i used to go and brief the jhz
classes the the junior officer training
classes and and briefed mine okay well
there you go one of the things that
i used to tell these guys was hey listen
when it comes to
when it comes to the rules of engagement
when it comes to the law of armed
conflict you have to not just do what
you think is right you have to do what
you think what you have to do not just
what is you think is right but what is
legal
and here's the reason and and leif had
to have this conversation leif had a
senior officer in the room when i was
explaining this to these young guys like
yourself that
what's what people think is right
what you you take 16 seals and you say
you give them a case example of is this
right in your own personal moral code
you're going to get 16 different answers
you're going to get somewhere else i
said oh yeah this this this person's uh
insurgent we'll kill them or this
person's an insurgent oh well we we
should we shouldn't hurt them because we
can reform them you can have all these
kind of wild different answers
so what you the only thing you can
actually follow isn't what an individual
quote thinks is right
you have to follow what is actually
legal
and i made that i always made that very
clear with my guys hey listen this is
what you can do this is what you cannot
do
and here's why and of course in any
leadership situation it's important to
explain the why
and you know for instance in ramadi
there was a bunch of reasons why you
can't go out and
shoot an innocent person well first of
all yeah it's morally wrong second of
all everyone would know about it
immediately so it's not like it's not
like i could have a sniper going oh you
know i'll sneak in a shot over here no
one's gonna know no we're in a city with
000 iraqi civilians that we there's a
mayor there's a police force there's a
there's a governor there's a whole
there's teachers and doctors inside that
city
you kill an innocent civilian
everybody's going to know about it and
by the way all those iraqi government
officials
they have relationships with the brigade
commanders with the battalion commanders
with the company commanders we're all
talking
so if you think oh i'm going to shoot
some innocent person get away that
you're never going to get away with it
it's not happening and
on top of that we are now losing the war
when you go out and kill an innocent
civilian you're giving
you're giving propaganda to
the enemy
and you're creating more insurgents by
killing an innocent person
so you have to not just explain hey
legally you can't do this but also
here's why you can't do it
uh
i was speaking to a group of army
leaders one time and i i said
hey in any in any platoon you're gonna
have a sociopath in there you have
somebody that's you give them the
opportunity to kill
or maybe even you don't
they might take advantage of that
they're gonna look for an opportunity to
kill they're going to look for an
opportunity to torture someone they're
going to look for an opportunity to rape
a woman like you take
a platoon
you're going to have that in there and i
got some looks from the crowd kind of
like oh that's not that's not realistic
and
no kidding two weeks later i was uh
doing a podcast with jordan peterson and
before we started recording i said hey
let me ask you a question here's what i
told this group of army guys i said in
your platoon you're gonna have at least
one person that's a sociopath
is that an accurate statement and he
says how many people are in a platoon
well in a platoon 40 50.
um
and he goes oh you know
i won't try and imitate jordan peterson
you know he basically oh yes definitely
and then he said
because it's like one in a hundred in
normal society that you have a sociopath
but
the the army or the marine corps is not
normal society you've already screened
out a bunch of pacifists right you've
already screened out a bunch of people
that are definitely not sociopaths and
so to have you probably actually have
two or three sociopaths inside your
platoon
and and and then look you also get some
guys that just
you know like like sean son shunstrom
he's not necessarily a sociopath but
maybe you know who knows how this guy
was raised maybe occasionally somebody
gets smacked around you know
occasionally you beat someone up um
violence is part of you know culture in
some parts of america and some families
in america that's what you grew up with
so that's what you get
so to once again to answer your question
you got to put you got to put the very
clear guard rails in place that say hey
look this is what we're doing that's
what we're not doing and then you have
to have the
the consistency that when you say
something
the guys know that you are not playing
around and that you are going to follow
through with whatever it is you say
and and and i think where guys get
caught sometimes from a leadership
perspective is they don't put out those
guard rails
and then when ben crosses the line and
you do something you weren't supposed to
do i feel kind of bad cause i didn't
even tell you not to do it
so i'm looking at you going well i guess
i'm gonna you know send you to court
marshall now and you're going wait a
second you know we killed three guys on
that last operation and four guys on the
operation before that now you're mad at
me because i killed somebody
well what were the circumstances well
you didn't talk to me about any
circumstances well you got to know the
rules of engagement well i know the
rules of engagement that seem like that
way to me so you see where i'm going
with this
i have to be very clear about what the
line is and why we cannot cross it
it also seems like
um like in an extreme team environment
like i said like in football it seemed
like there were there was some
sociopaths there too and actually i
actually know of one who's i think he's
still in jail right now but
he um in an uh an extreme team
environment it's like people who are
just normal people where i'm down for
the team they get influenced just to do
stuff good and bad
just because of the team environment
do you find that a lot
100 where it's like i mean actually you
know what now that i'm thinking of like
the massacres certainly yes for sure i
mean i'm asking that's definitely what
happened like although that's what we're
doing okay we're ready for it you know
i've been talking a lot about this
lately is just the fact that people
human beings are so
so their brains are so pliable you can
program a person so easily to believe
whatever and by the way it's happening
all day long right now with all these
people out there that are looking at
their social media all day long that's
they're getting programmed you're
getting programmed you're receiving
information you don't even know what
you're
you're seeing and it's happening right
now you know the the the propaganda
that's coming out from both sides from
from ukraine right it's like you have
people going high into the right on
whatever
image that they saw
and you got to take everything that's
coming out of there with a grain of salt
but
what it's showing you is how easily
influenced human beings are and that's a
really negative thing but it's also a
really positive thing because you as a
leader have the ability to say hey
here's what's going on here's what we
need to do here's why we need to do it
here's why we can go to this line and we
can't go past it and those are the rules
that's that's what you need to do
if you start to
allow
slack
and then you develop a habit of allowing
slack you're gonna have a freaking issue
you're gonna have you're gonna you're
gonna end up with issues if you don't
have the ability to say hey listen dude
this is not we're not doing that
uh
one thing that's interesting in the in
the sealed teams is most of the guys
want to do a good job and have a good
reputation
so when you say hey
hey ben
we're not doing that
or hey ben it looks seem like you were
thinking about doing something let me
tell you why we're not doing it you
don't go it's [__] no you go yeah i
got it boss thanks for explaining that
to me
it's not that hard but if i'm weak
and you know that you end up with that
dynamic in the military where you have a
really strong personality or a really
strong chief or really yeah really
strong and a brand new officer yep and
if if
that that can that's a classic scenario
right that's the that's the damn platoon
right that's the the movie platoon right
you have you have uh barnes
and you have whatever that officer's
name was and he just gets run rough shot
over by barnes
and
that's a perfect example that's a
perfect example hey you're a new guy
shut up you don't know what you're
talking about this is the only way to
win this okay well yes sir or yes yes
sergeant barnes and then you have a guy
like
elias
who
is saying hey but what are you doing but
he doesn't have the strength to back it
up to and to
to
get his platoon officer on board with
what's happening so
it's a classic thing to watch out for
um
all right let's jump back into the book
here go a little bit more forward going
to chapter four
chapter four
draper kaufman and the course that
cracked the atlantic wall then laid the
first bricks of the legends of
the legend of navy's special warfare so
there you go
um
and this this really
you should have you should have saved
that dramatic you know
intake for the last chapter
that's the longest one they get there's
only one that's short there's only one
more that's coming that short um
i'm going to read a little chunk from
the book here
landing at 0 6 25
one of the earliest crews to arrive
gregory and the army engineers had
dragged their rubber boat into the surf
lashed it to a wooden stake and run for
the farthest belt of hedgehogs
it looked impossible to be there without
being hit
one of karnowski's men remembered
afterward
it looked even worse without a helmet
despite the chaos karnowski and the
demolitioneers laid their charges ran
out their prime record tied in and blew
their charge the first shot was
magnificent remembered one man
after it nothing else was
as soon as the charge blew machine guns
opened up from everywhere and men pushed
their bellies into the sand conrad
millis a quiet california carpenter made
chief petty officer for the example he
had set during training grabbed the
primer
grabbed the primer cord reel and
sprinted for the next row of obstacles
he was identified later by the pack of
explosives around his neck
with a big hole in his chest
as the waves of infantry landed the
demolition job grew even more
complicated terrified soldiers either
did not notice the purple smoke warnings
swirling around them or did not care i
thought i'd never get one of the
infantrymen out from behind a piling a
demolitioneer confessed later he moved
out just in time
and our second shot went off
as obstacles blew apart the army and
navy sections began working together
mingling as a single team regardless of
the advancing tide lieutenant gregory
having destroyed the tank crippling
hedgehogs at the far end of the beach
turned away from the enemy and splashed
back into the surf like a man possessed
he waited or swam to each remaining
stake where he waited until someone
threw him a charge then using the
lessons taught to him by the ncdus
stretched his arms as far as they would
reach and placed his bomb next to
rommel's
then blew them to nothing
[Music]
[Applause]
so
d-day
um
you you talk about this being the most
consequential day in in the history of
nsw there's a hundred and eight 190 navy
demolitioneers
32 of them are killed
65 are wounded so that's a total number
of
casualties being at 97. this is 51
51 casualties
yeah i mean just in contribution or just
in sacrifice it's a
um
it matches any other
tragedy or
that nsw has experienced it's
far
far exceeds anything at least in any
single day experience and this happens
mostly in the space of
around three or four hours
gap assault teams
3 and 14 11 they're all destroyed even
before i mean right 11 is destroyed as
soon as its ramp drops 3 and 14 are
destroyed destroyed before the ramps
even drop there
with mortars mortars and uh just about
everybody in a board is killed
um
it's the
it's the most important day of the 20th
century i mean it's the day that
determines um
uh whether or not hitler is going to be
removed from the continent
um
and it's uh
it's tough to you know write this
chapter and not make it you know
outshine everything else it's a um it's
too much the chapter was twice as long
when i uh you know when i finished the
first draft it was
i i wanted to i didn't want to leave
anything behind i wanted you know every
every gap assault team every uh every
ncdu to you know have full
representation i think there's 21
gap assault teams that land i ultimately
had to you know cut cut cut cut cut and
try and you know consolidate as much as
possible just so it was a readable
chapter and i also had to like figure
out what the hell am i trying to say in
this thing you know i
expected that
writing history of the seal teams or
writing how the navy had been the first
to create this type of unit i always
expected that it'd be tough to justify
how i put the you know the army or
marine corps chapters in and it wouldn't
be tough to you know justify the navy
chapters the navy chapters would just
sort of write themselves i just had to
say what happened just say what happened
i found the opposite to be true because
you know it was
you know with the army chapters and the
marine corps chapters all you're really
just you know trying to show like why
these units failed or why they
why the you know their
senior leaders pulled the rug out from
under him the navy chapters you're
having to
you know show how um you know a unit
like the ncdus which is you know created
just to solve one problem and that
problem is the obstacles in france or
the obstacles on the coast how did why
is that relevant
you know to the ultimate creation of go
anywhere you know naval commandos
so i
um
it took a long time it took multiple
drafts before i realized that the point
of this whole thing or the the relevance
to that story is not so much um
you know the fact that they were
you know just blowing up obstacles it's
the fact that they left
such an impression on the navy's leaders
um after that you know there's you know
there's all these um you know episodes
of of naval bravery you know the there's
the experience of the uh
um
the the the destroyers that ultimately
save the day that pushed the army ashore
these destroyers you know they're um
they're on the outskirts of uh of the
battle until um admiral hall uh uh the
army the army is looking at what's
happening on omaha beach there's there's
successful landings on gold sword in
juneau there's successful landings at
utah beach everywhere the you know the
the
landing to get troops ashore on d-day is
going well except here at omaha omaha
you know the army commanders like we
might need to pull our troops off they
might need to do something they've never
trained to do which is a full-scale
evacuation in front of the enemy
admiral hall
who has
made it a point to make sure that he's
in charge of the invasion until the
forces are firmly established ashore
says no we're not doing that and he does
what you know nobody has done up to that
point which is push
uh destroyers right up to the uh to the
as close to the coast as possible it
pushes them 800 yards away
from from the coast that's insane
destroyers they they come in at flank
speed and as soon as they get to about
where their holes are about three feet
off the bottom they all turn left and
they all start going right along the
coast so you have all this bravery that
happens as soon as they get you know to
a point to the end of omaha beach you
think all these ships are going to turn
and some of them do some of them have
enough
depth where they're able to turn around
the ships that don't they just they just
reverse reverse
and they just start going backwards and
they're blasting
away at these uh pill boxes and
structures and some in some cases they
are
they're blasting underneath
the pill boxes so the pill boxes full of
germans just start tumbling
off the uh
off the escarpment
um
so in all i think i've seen that
represented no in like in saving private
ryan or anything like that no and
everybody 800 yards off the beach is
freaking close
everybody walks away or everybody you
know comes away from you know the
reading of omaha beach as this
as this victory of american infantry
over you know the german obstacles
um and that's true but there's also
another truth and that's the um
that's the commitment or that's the
force that the navy brought to bear on
that day and then and the army would not
have gotten off those killing fields or
other killing beaches without the
contribution of the u.s navy
but what i found was the point of this
chapter
was that with all of that with all the
the the contribution that the navy had
made with all the bravery um
the
the navy walks away from that battle
with knowing that the the greatest
contribution that they'd given that day
was with the naval or with with the
ncdus with the naval combat demolition
units um they are awarded you know uh
some this six navy crosses um more
silver stars and you can shake a stick
at they've got they they award the nc to
use only one of three uh presidential
unit citations that are awarded from a
naval unit on omaha beach
um
right so the reason that that's so
important is because uh when the navy
when the dust settles uh and the navy is
looking at you know their entire
contribution uh at omaha beach they know
that uh they know how important the
ncd's contribution was and more
importantly they know how important
uh the na the curriculum was that
created these units
and that curriculum
i don't know if anybody uh in charge of
omaha beach had realized what curriculum
had created them
but
there are people that know
and that curriculum is now
um
validated because of uh of everything
the ncdus did
and that curriculum as you know was you
know developed by draper kaufman yeah
and the main part of that curriculum is
hell week
yeah the
the crucible of that curriculum is hell
week and then and and the reason that
it's it's developed is because you know
it's the closest thing
the least draper kaufman had ever
come in contact with two combat
i mean it's a
um
it'll at least it matches the experience
that draper kaufman had when it came to
combat he'd been in you know we can get
to draper kaufman but um
it prepared the guys that went to omaha
beach
for
exactly what they experienced you know
they were
um
they were wet they were cold i mean they
spent almost 48 hours on on ships that
were you know often
some of these ships were sinking uh
prior to they were so overwhelmed with
uh with water and rain and um
that you know they went into battle cold
hungry um often you know nearly all of
them were seasick they're all wretching
their guts out so they don't have
anything in them when they hit the
beaches um and then the uh the chaos
that unfolds around them is uh
they've they've gotten at least a taste
of it
on the beaches at fort pierce they'd you
know they'd you know the the so solid
day i mean they'd been
peppered with all these bombs going off
around them um they were probably better
prepared for what uh what they
encountered than any other troops on
omaha beach
yeah the the hell week thing is
definitely
interesting
um
because it is
it's shocking when you when you look at
it and you know the kind of people that
show up
just the numbers of people that show up
i mean
a class will start with a couple hundred
people
and by the time they're done with hell
week they'll be down to
10 15 20
of that
and
these are people that
enlisted
in the navy that had a goal that told
their families they were going to be
navy seals that dedicated six years of
their life to signing that dotted line
they trained they worked they went to
boot camp they gave up whatever other
possibilities they had in life and
they've poured all that into this one
singular dream without a fallback plan
too with not with the crappiest fault
there's a fallback plan it just sucks it
sucks but i mean it's not like if you go
to the marine corps like and you don't
you know get into marshall you could
still be a pretty awesome marine yeah
you're a freaking infantryman in the
marine corps which is a beautiful thing
and same thing with the army special
operations so you don't make it through
special forces training okay cool you're
a freaking ground pounder which is
awesome
the navy you don't make it through seal
training and if you have the mindset
where you want to be some kind of a
machine gun toten bad ass
well guess what you don't make it
through seal training you are literally
not going to be a machine gun toting
badass at all
and and and that's a horrible a horrible
fate for these young guys but they know
that that's their fate
and yet with that fate
they still ring that bell
and
people from every background people that
were
division one athletes of every division
one athlete wrestlers football players
uh you name it swimmers runners they all
quit
people that were you know raised with a
silver spoon in their mouth that went to
ivy league schools they quit people that
were raised in the ghetto with really
hard lives they quit some of them make
it some of them quit same with the ivy
league some of them make it someone
quit it's a crazy
crucible
and and we still don't even understand
it we don't understand who's gonna make
it no i think the only thing that we we
really know is where it came from that's
about it and we don't
and
i mean as much as draper kaufman wrote
and i came i mean
when i
so i went to his daughter's house in
indiana and uh
she let me have you know two days just
to go through this entire this humongous
file cabinet he kept everything and i
there was letters i mean tons of letters
between you know him family members
friends
um the one thing that he never really
kind of um talked about at least
contemporaneously he only really talked
about it in his oral history was this
you know this hell week that he invented
i mean and nobody really i mean all the
guys that went through it talked about
it he didn't even talk about you know
his own experience going through it so
after he created hell week and he didn't
really create hell week all he did was
compress
you know that uh that curriculum that
you know phil buckley and all those
other scouts and raiders they
established it all draper kaufman did
was like okay i like this this is eight
weeks long that's great let's put it
let's make all this five days
it's like
how are you gonna do that well you're
just gonna cut out all the stuff that
you don't need like you know like sleep
well just you know keep keeping it and
he did it himself i mean he not only you
know it creates this he puts himself
through the training at 32 years old
yeah and he's a terrible athlete he's a
terrible athlete he's a terrible swimmer
he can't he can't qualify him his
eyesight he can't even qualify
for the standards that he sets for
himself or first sets for the program
like he would not be he would not
qualify for you know the course that he
creates
then he does it
uh you visited
did you you visited where omaha beach
you visited
fort pierce yeah how is that with the
with the breadth of knowledge that you
have when you're down there
it's incredible um
it's um
there's nothing quite like you know
going to the places that you're writing
about if i could have gone i wish i
could have gone to every single place
that i wrote about i've and i've kind of
made it a mental mandate for me of
future books i'm i'm never going to
write about anything unless i go to the
place
the
there's a weight at omaha i mean there's
a way to you know all of all of normandy
and um
i mean you
i'm not sure uh which point you you
should go to the cemetery at omaha beach
if you should go to the cemetery first
before you go to the beachheads and
before you go to all the battlefields in
point to hawk or if you should go see
the battlefields and point the hawk and
everything and then go to the cemetery
either way
you're going to that cemetery and you're
going to walk around in the the one
thing you're going to see and there's a
poem by robert frost before you go into
that cemetery and it said something like
you know
don't talk
just
listen just look
and uh note the dates on these
headstones and
note how young they were and they died
for you
and it's it's overwhelming
and then to take that
and then to go see the places where all
of these guys were you see dog green dog
red and all the all the beaches and then
you go to point hawk you can't even look
over the cliffs i mean look you see
where these rangers they climbed up like
and then i mean
the germans at the top are cutting ropes
and they're throwing grenades and
they're leaning over the cliffs so
they're machine gunning them off the
ropes and still they came
um
and with the the section that you read
of uh karnowski
i he dropped his helmet in the water
before you know the operation even
started before the you know the
um
before the ramp even dropped he did not
have a helmet and he you know spent he
ran you know from
i mean and who where was he gonna get a
helmet everybody else needed their
helmet there's no other helmets to take
and he you know ran
ran ashore and
um
wasn't able to get a helmet you know for
almost 24 hours he finally finally found
a helmet that wasn't attached to
somebody that
he was able to take
but yeah and how about fort pierce
fort pierce is really something
we can talk about for fort pierce a bit
later there's a uh
uh recently went to uh fort pierce for
their annual muster and um
but yeah fort pierce is one of the first
places i went and um
i didn't i didn't quite understand like
uh what the island was like with the or
the separation of hutchinson island was
because fort pierce is the actual town
it's on the mainland where hutchinson
island where you know that's what we
colloquially will call or that's what we
call um you know fort pierce it's
actually two separate islands there's
it's an intercoastal island that
separates you know from the indian river
and the atlantic ocean the atlantic is
you know kind of a crushing surf and you
can see all the rocks that are there i
mean um
the
the idea of rock portage and everything
like that we all you know it's you know
we always think of it as you know right
there at the hotel
yeah you get this fairytale hotel you
know and and these you know you know
jagged you know humongous you know rocks
um they have the exact same rocks right
there at fort pierce and they did the
exact same rock portage and it was just
as dangerous then as it is now
um
but you you can see it i mean you uh you
can see you know this is the birth place
this is where it all happened and it
wasn't just the birthplace of you know
the ncus and the scouts and raiders but
it was the birthplace of you know kind
of uh
american special operations thinking
everybody took a turn at fort pierce
anybody was going to do any sort of
amphibious training any special unit was
going to take a stop at fort pierce the
rangers the uh
the army raiders that uh that you know
uh went up the cebu river on the dallas
they all everybody everybody uh took a
turn through fort pierce it was the um
um
it was the garden bed of uh of special
operations thinking at the time so
um
yeah
you might just mention the the ut seal
museum which is down there in fort
pierce and it's freaking unbelievable
it's an awesome awesome thing that
they're continuing to build
down there yeah um couldn't have done
the book without them
oh really like as far as them giving you
information and point you in the right
direction
you know it was the first place that i
went to and it was um
this was i went there before i even knew
what an archive was
and their archive
is um
it's not it's not really an art i mean
it's a it's a room with a bunch of file
cabinets in it and the first time that i
went in there
you know nobody
um
uh
nobody told me what i couldn't look at i
mean i just
i just went in there with a camera and
you know i got to work i didn't know
where world war ii was i didn't know
where korea was vietnam but it's all in
there and i was gathering stuff that you
know
um
i didn't know what i was looking at i
took a thousand pictures away my first
day at an archive and it took me a month
to go through them and just to sort of
you know figure out this is this this is
that you know this is a
this is an operations plan for okinawa
this is a you know this is an op order
for um you know a trained demolition
raid in korea something like that i mean
um
but yeah that was the first time that i
you know really kind of
got the evidence of the cold case
mystery that i was trying to you know
sort out
um
all right
let's move on to a and again uh i've
already told you if you're listening to
this to buy this book and to do it as
quickly as you possibly can um we are
literally just hitting wave tops on this
stuff there's so much incredible
information
obviously d-day i mean we i read one i
read two paragraphs about d-day there's
the entire entire incredible section
about all of it about
draper kaufman who
we we covered him a lot on the first the
first time you were on because he's such
a
such an incredible character he's not
the guy that you would think created or
was one of the one of the lead role
players in creating this organization
that we have
um he's a guy and you know you know you
pointed out on that first podcast is
he's a guy that was
he didn't really want to be he didn't
want to be some kind of commando he
wanted to be a
naval officer that was in charge of a
ship and it just
wasn't going to happen for him his
eyesight was bad it wasn't gonna happen
and he just made things happen he looked
around and said all right well what can
i do and what does the military need
what does the
what does the the the fighting people
need because he wasn't necessarily going
to work for america either he's like
who's fighting i'm in
yeah i think that's important i mean for
anybody who's trying to be a seal right
now i mean
whether you succeed or whether you don't
i mean there's so many ways to serve
your country i mean here's a guy who
spent four years at naval academy hoping
to fulfill his dream to be a destroyer
sailor he wants to just be on a
destroyer that's all he wants
and it's you know the
rug's pulled out from under him right at
the moment he's ready to take the fleet
and he's got to come up with plan b
he doesn't know what plan b is going to
be but he doesn't you know let that
paralyze him
he
when he doesn't see a way to contribute
to his country he makes one up and then
he makes one up again the thing that
just keeps the his guiding star in that
whole process is just like i want to be
useful i want to i want to you know help
and i want to be as close as i can to
you know to that to that help and if i
can
you know if i can't fight then i'll
carry i'll carry stretchers i'll be an
ambulance driver if i can't uh
be an raf pilot or if i can't be on a
british ship then i will uh dispose the
bombs that are landing in central london
if i can't uh be a ship driver in the us
navy then i will teach the rest of the
navy how to dismantle bombs i'll do
whatever i can and then when he's
uh
anyway yeah that's it's incredible
incredible story
that
it's just crazy it's a crazy thing he's
he becomes a french ambulance driver and
then becomes a british
naval officer and then finally they
eventually let him into the u.s navy
that's crazy
yeah i mean if you want to like
like for somebody and his and his dad is
one of the most famous destroyer
skippers in the navy and his dad i mean
who clearly loves his son because i mean
you see the
you see the paralysis and you know like
we talked about last time the paralysis
and
the letters between the two like he
knows that his son's gonna be committed
or sent on these you know terribly
dangerous uh missions uh it's never been
done before like when before draper
kaufman heads out with udt5 uh to scout
the beaches for saipan his dad knows
that these guys are going into combat
with nothing
and the letters are you know he signs
them off you know just the same way you
know anybody any any other dad would you
know
i love you lots and lots of luck and
that's all i can do like that's all i
can do for you
he's not getting your seed on his son's
behalf
craziness um
chapter five
the evolving contest that created the
merman of war
world war two's only indispensable
special operations unit so we we we have
that controversy about the men yes
we don't really like that term we don't
but it's got it's what got used right
well yeah i mean yeah they used it i
mean they that's the
i think that was the the wrigley
spearmint gum
uh hour that was on the radio i mean
that's where it goes that's where it
came from they call it they came from
they called the merman of war yeah
unfortunate little piece of history but
we can't change it all right go to the
book here real quick in the in the late
summer of 1943 right about the same time
that draper kaufman was putting himself
through hell week u.s commanders in the
pacific were about to initiate two
campaigns with one ultimate objective
the the invasion of japan
blocked by a swath of ocean five times
the size of the sahara and whose every
atoll had been turned into a japanese
fortress the strategy to accomplish this
objective was one in which the allies
would leapfrog most islands especially
the most robustly defended
let them wither on the vine said douglas
macarthur and seize a handful upon which
they could build
airfields substantial enough to support
the long range four engine bombers
needing to needed to soften up the next
handful on the way to mainland japan
in the south pacific this path would
progress from the mountainous jungles of
guadalcanal to a nearby group of similar
islands many well-charted and populated
and all of them battlefields large
enough for the us army's and macarthur's
ambitions
in the central pacific this path would
start some two thousand miles west of
hawaii in the gilbert island chain the
first lily pads large enough to support
bomber-sized airfields but so small so
remote so daunting that their volcanic
spines of white sand and green palms
could almost be mistaken for the rigid
backs of a thousand sea monsters
and there was only one branch of service
that could lead the hunt against those
the same branch that would go on to
break hitler's atlantic wall but
employing an altogether different kind
of method
indeed a method unlike any in military
history
so you're setting us up pretty strong
there right
for this
for the merman
true
true this is the first time the navy is
kind of the master of the battle space
first time in history
and that's going to play into a
significant role because
we need to get onto these islands yeah
we need to figure out how to get onto
these islands and there's this weird
little gap this weird little gap of
information this weird little gap of
tactical control
that no one really knows how to fill
yeah
uh
what's the what's the myth behind
tarawa
tarawa is um
every history that i've ever read about
the seal teams
starts with a
a vignette about tarawa
and that
tarawa is this um
this meat grinder battle in 1943
in which
the marines
they take this island in the central
pacific
and in three days the marines lose as
many men as they've lost in the entire
six-month battle for guadalcanal
it's
it's the first time that americans
realize that this is going to be
this is going to be something this is
going to this is like the shiloh moment
the civil war where
americans realize this is going to be
every bit is terrible it's going to be a
monster
and you're going to have to do this on
island on every island across the
pacific to get to japan if we're going
to
uh carry this you know fdr's uh policy
of uh unconditional surrender
uh against the japanese this it's going
to be a bloody bloody uh battle or
bloody way to do it um
and
so the idea is that you know
part of the reason that taro was such a
meat grinder is because the landing
craft couldn't get past the coral reefs
which is true
the landing craft couldn't get past the
coral reefs and it's going to be a
problem on every subsequent battle
but the marines had already anticipated
that the navy had already anticipated
that and they had fielded a new
technological solution to overcome it
which was the lvt or the amphibious
tractor it wasn't a landing craft as
much as it was um you know a tractor
that could float and as soon as they got
into a coral it would just crawl right
over it
i think they brought 125
to tarawa
there
i think there's only a handful left by
the end of the first day uh the rest are
uh technologically they're broke they're
broken um so those the subsequent days
uh the only marines that can land to
support um are you know they're kept on
the outskirts of the the battle by this
coral reef so they have to you know
drive up the higgins boats they drop
their ramps the marines rush out into
the coral and they jump into the lagoon
and then they've got this 3 000 yard
wade to shore where they've got to you
know deal with mortars machine gun fire
um and there's a you know pilots that
are flying above this uh this tragedy
and and they
the the record is that you know this
lagoon this you know pristine blue
lagoon it never um it's never free of
red i mean it's just it's a it's a sea a
wash with red the entire three days
um
and and it's uh it leaves an impression
on everybody who encounters it um
just because of the you know the marines
that are being pulled from this lagoon
for the next three days they're complete
there's no they don't have hair they're
completely swollen it's a it's a crime
scene every every single person in there
that's a crime scene
um
so the
you know the myth is that uh because of
this you know the navy decides that they
have to
on every subsequent battle they've got
to
create a unit that can
destroy the coral so the landing craft
can get in there which is true sort of
the landing craft you know the the coral
is a problem and it does need to be
destroyed
um the bigger issue um that creates the
udts which ultimately creates the seal
team is not so much the coral as it is
uh
the fact that the navy um is
at this point in the war they're not uh
given access to the marine corps special
units because the marine corps like i
said in chapter one they have uh
elevated their status to such a point
that they are now on parity with the
navy so up until that point the marine
or the the navy had this impression that
the marine corps was a subservient
service and on every battle navy
admirals could trump marine corps
generals
but at this point in the war marine
corps generals
they're
they're just as uh they're they're on
they're on par with their their navy
admirals so if the navy wants to send
out reconnaissance troops a special
reconnaissance mission or if they want
to conduct a raid or anything like that
they've got to go through the marine
corps because they're the only guys that
have or they're the only service
that has a unit that could do any of
those things
so
when turner turner is the um the
commander of the fifth amphibious force
he does not uh he hates this policy
absolutely hates it he's the he's the
biggest
uh
um
i describe him as the the first uh
personification of an actual life ahab
in um
uh the pacific theater he is
he's the biggest
he's the biggest dick that's ever served
in the the the surface navy um
he's a he's a he's a tyrant almost and
he absolutely hates the fact that he
does not have
uh
control of the marines in the way that
he anticipated having control of the
marines so
he's not as concerned about destroying
the coral as he is with having his own
unit
that he can control that he can send out
to find out information
and either find it out cut it out
whatever that's why he creates the udts
it's it's not a it's not a issue of
coral as it is uh
controlled control yeah
one of the characters
that you uh cut i guess james jones from
the recon company what's this guy all
about
james jones is uh so one of the options
that the navy had uh prior to this uh
sort of re-realignment or reassessment
of native marine corps authority what
would have been the vac recon company
the the vac
fifth amphibious force vac
um
that would have been a unit that
kelly turner admiral turner would have
had access to to send on special special
missions special assignments including
missions to destroy coral fine coral
things like that
but
now that the marine corps is you know
has the status that it does you know it
doesn't really have access to this unit
anymore but it's a it's sort of the um
the replacement for the marine corps
raiders it's not as big as the raiders
were intended to be but um they they
they sort of form this unit around james
jones he's a he's a really interesting
uh character he was a a tractor salesman
in africa before the war
he and just by being a tractor salesman
he manages to pick up multiple languages
he's a really really interesting guy
and he was one of the initial
guys put in charge of the
the observer group which was the unit
that ultimately became the scouts and
raiders
as a side note i uh
he is the father of james jones the
national of
um
um obama's first national security
adviser
uh great father or grandfather father
wow he's his father and i so when i was
doing my initial research for this i was
trying to get an interview with with him
no no dice
i i was close i had uh i was going nice
bro
i was going back back and forth with his
uh secretary he has a uh
not a non-profit but like a strategic
think think tank and i was going back
and forth with his uh secretary
couldn't make it work
so no dice you're right no dice no dice
and well then what happened with the
with the
with them the vac recon company um they
uh initially um
uh
they
they have some pretty uh
pretty impressive raids uh right around
uh the time of uh
um
tarawa they they raid uh a little uh
island of apamama uh that's you know
it's kind of a it's a similar um an
island style raid they use the same
submarine
that they the raiders use for make an
island
they they
it's it's kind of a textbook
island raid um you know navy and marine
corps cooperation uh but after um after
that
the
they don't really do much until uh the
battle of okinawa and the reason that
they're important is because they're
kind of
once the udt are created you can see how
important the udt become and how less
important every other unit becomes and
at one point
the vac recon company doesn't really
have a mission so they assign them to
the udts and so they take every marine
that's in the vac recon company that can
swim
and they plug them into uh
a udt
do they actually get transferred to the
navy or no no they don't get transferred
and by okinawa they they separate
themselves from the udt again
and they're back to doing their sort of
island raids but until okinawa there's
not a lot of other like little satellite
islands to do the things that they they
were trained to do
and then what about the the uss burfish
recon
of of yap this was udt udt10 operation
what was going on there
yeah that was one of the um
that's in august of 44 there's a series
of
sort of secret reconnaissance so after
the tinian reconnaissance
which draper kaufman leads
it's a it's a combined reconnaissance
between
vac recon so the marine recon and udt
swimmers
the navy really sees the potential of
doing these night secret reconnaissance
of various islands so the next group of
islands that the
pacific planters are hoping to capture
are in the palau so peleliu that whole
episode in the war so one of the
satellite islands of pelulu is this
island of yap
and
so the uss burfish with a uh contingent
of udt swimmers uh half of whom are
not haven't really been trained in the
traditional udt uh curriculum which
they've established at maui but
half of them are actually oss maritime
swimmers
they send a combined
recon team ashore at yap
three of the swimmers get separated from
their boat the boat ends up paddling
back to the the uss burfish which is the
submarine
they come back out the next night trying
to recover uh the swimmers hoping that
they've managed to stay alive ashore and
not get captured
but they
after the second night they realize
they're not going to be able to have a
link up and
three swimmers get left behind and they
are three
they're the as far as i know they're the
only three missing um well there's
there's a couple of others but um there
are three unaccounted for nsw members
out there we still have not recovered
their bodies
we think
based off of the research of one
archivist at
the national archives who's also
moonlights as a historian himself nate
patch he's put together a pretty um
pretty convincing argument that the the
bodies are probably a babble thu app
they're buried with a handful of other
uh captured american aviators
but we have not not found them there's
an effort right now by project recover
to try and track their bodies down
all right um
but
likely they were captured they were
bounced around the japanese tried to you
know do a cover-up of their execution
they said that they were put on a
transport uh bound for the south pacific
back to the philippines uh based off of
the research that nate patch did looks
like that was all just manufactured and
they were killed right there
so that
that chapter kind of kind of brings the
the underwater demolition teams
sort of how how we really got the
traction going all the underwater
demolition teams and then in chapter six
you start going into just the
the
a totally different
aspect of warfare i mean a totally
different aspect of warfare chapter six
is called the contest for guerrilla war
in china and the organization that had
no damn business fighting it the us
navy's army of
soldiers
and this is definitely one of the
wildest
sections in the book
all pretty much
centered around this this guy miles
um who
this is
like a whole book unto itself of course
i guess i say that over again over again
for all your characters but this guy's
insane
no i mean quite literally at the end i
guess he is insane right
yes i mean the effort breaks him it
completely breaks him he's uh
um
he's committed uh to a a mental
institution um it takes him uh several
months to and part of that's drug
induced i mean he's self-medicating by
the end of the war um
taking an incredible uh cocktail worth
of medicine just to you know either stay
awake go to sleep and then uh deal with
the the pain that he's dealing with and
the fevers too he's got almost constant
malaria throughout the entire war but
yeah i mean of all the guys that i i
mean i say there's kind of a um a horse
race uh in my head for who's the
weirdest character
and miles is definitely leaning for the
tape i mean he's like
yeah i mean he's he's fascinating in um
in the sense of how unremarkable he
seems like when you meet miles like he
seems like any other ship officer that
you would encounter just like if you you
know did a visit or any of the you know
other guys you know he's he's not a
physical specimen he's kind of you know
nerdy looking he's just forgettable
he's totally forgettable he's not like
he's not like a
exotic person he's not like uh he's not
like a lawrence of arabia type character
at all and yet he does every i mean what
he contributes to the war is every bit
as remarkable as a lawrence of arabia
yeah i mean we run over the figures on
the last time you were on this podcast
but he had that there this massive
guerrilla force that he ends up running
with no business doing it with no
business and that that's from the title
no damn business that comes from another
navy officer one of miles friends he's
like we have no damn business doing this
i found the letter like if if you know
one of miles's friends
thinks that you know we the navy has no
damn business then what hope did we
really ever have yeah and yet the impact
that they had was completely strategic
they end up killing
somewhere in the neighborhood of 25 000
i think enemy japanese soldiers but more
important tying up a million of them
only lost a handful of americans
it doesn't account for the number of
chinese lost i mean yeah but you're
right i mean the the chinese
contribution is is you know it's
unaccounted for and you know significant
um but yeah only some six six american
uh six american deaths in the entire
effort which is a you know the effort
you know stretches from 1942 to all the
way to 1945.
i mean it's
you're absolutely right there should be
a book written about this and when i
when i got into this i didn't want to
write this chapter i was so tired of not
so tired but i was like i was so anxious
to be done with world war ii when i
finished my udt chapter and i was so
ready to move on to korea i just wanted
different scenery different a different
record group at the national archives
when i got to this point i mean all i
wanted to do was leave and i was just
trying to like you know take this china
stuff and kind of stuff it into like an
introductory section of my korean war
chapter and i couldn't do it one chapter
or one page became two pages and became
three pages and four pages like mother
mother
i had to write a whole new chapter it
derailed my entire timeline for you know
finishing the book what's the movie
potential for uh
for this for this i think that i mean i
think
you know if you have to if i was gonna
say like which of these
i think they could all be movies
but you know if you haven't seen we've
seen you know saving private ryan um
we've never seen a um
a representation of a guerrilla war um
like what happened in china in world war
ii it could totally and miles is such a
you know an interestingly an interesting
character he could be like
i mean he
he's interesting in the fact that he's
so boring but he does
i mean he's i mean he survives 40
assassination attempts
um he's uh he's a naval officer who's
involved in and probably more ground
combat than anybody else uh in history
yeah including a freaking cavalry charge
on camels yeah
it's nuts it's nuts the whole thing is
nice but yeah that the movie potential
of chapter six is is high i think the
movie potential of you know the udt
chapter is just as high too i mean
that's
i mean the imagine scene or i i can see
a movie of you know these guys you know
totally
you know going into battle with just
knives and you know
fins and masks
that'd be pretty neat
uh you have another character that you
bring in here uh going to the book at 60
years old thick jowled and with white
hair parted just off center wild bill
donovan a nickname he had earned as a
volunteer leading soldiers through mud
gas and death on the western front
looked in his uniform nothing like the
head of an insatiable insatiable
unconventional warfare organization and
more like an overweight toddler playing
dress-up
for signs of the former one had to look
elsewhere first to his left breast where
he had humbly affixed a single ribbon
his medal of honor in effect saying to
his peers that no other awards mattered
and second to a career as an attorney as
a new york attorney and politician
occupations that had introduced him to
everyone from movie stars to mussolini
and taking him further around the world
than most presidents he had been to
siberia to size up bolsheviks to the far
east to hunt down business ethiopia to
tour the italian front the bauklins
turkey and spain as a presidential
president's unofficial envoy in past
ages a hero
millionaire like donovan could have
responded to a world crisis simply by
raising his own regiment equipping it
and leading it into battle
in the 20th century such impulses had
been curved by the increasing
complexities of modern warfare and a
corresponding bureaucracy that
recognized the limited value of
eccentric amateurs medal of honor or not
now blocked from commanding regular
troops donovan courageous
entrepreneurial
imaginative and most of all unstoppable
had set his sights on the only field of
action whose battle lines had not yet
been drawn
and on the one man who stood in his way
what's up with donovan dude
well it's an
it's an impossible um
uh contest i mean
donovan is
when i set out to write this not this
chapter but when i i set out to write an
oss chapter and i i was attracted to it
just because of donovan he is a
i mean
there should be a donovan movie he's
i mean all the you know the stories
about uh
um
j edgar hoover you know dressing up in
women's clothes like
these are rumors that donovan started
i mean he's responsible for so much and
you know when you say that you mean he
actually was responsible for starting
the rumors about j edgar hoover dressing
up in women's clothing he yes that's
what we're saying i'm saying yes he is
responsible i'm not saying that this
isn't hyperbole this is what this guy
did no and the reason he did that is
because at the time the oss and the fbi
were in some sort of competition uh
for the international intelligence
mission in one of them he wanted to do a
cross dresser he wanted to de-legitimize
his rival as best as he could i mean and
at the same time j edgar hoover was um
uh he was putting rumors out there that
donovan was having an affair with his
daughter-in-law so they were both at
each other from like so is there any
truth to the rumor of j edgar hoover
dressing up in women's clothing i don't
know about that but i think there is
suspicion that donovan was actually
having an affair with his
daughter-in-law yeah his son's like
yeah
that's that's pretty
uh and so how does he play into our into
our story here for for the development
of the seal teams so uh donovan's
important because donovan sees what the
navy is doing in china and he wants it
he doesn't think the navy should have
anything to do with this
donovan has established himself as the
the head of the international head of
the u.s intelligence organization which
he has understood
to include all sorts of special programs
so if there's going to be
a guerrilla warfare effort in china oss
is going to be in charge of it so he
comes to china
so first he tries to
rope miles into the oss and he
establishes miles as an oss not
operative but a head of an oss program
problem is
donovan also wants to send all of his
oss folks
to support saco um
but miles
miles starts to receive these guys and
they're all
you know
um a lot of these guys are you know
they're you know pretty interesting guys
but miles doesn't want anything to do
with them they're like wannabes i get
this
they're sort of like they because
because boondogglers because who miles
is getting is marine corps officers like
primarily right he's getting marine
corps officers in the beginning but what
he really wants are people that don't
know anything about china he doesn't
want racists oh
miles is
that weird he's the peculiar type of
officer who actually he likes the the
indigenous people that he's working with
he doesn't want them to um
i mean he's he's a perfect character for
you know you know today but at the time
like nobody really understands like
what's his hang up he he's infatuated
with china he's infatuated with the
chinese he thinks that these are
uh
you know members of the most you know
one of the most civilized um you know uh
countries on the planet um and he uh
has respect for them in the way that
other americans don't um he he totally
rejects uh the uh
the the orientalism or the
the superior american idea
in that way he's he's just like you know
t lawrence i mean he's um he's a
believer
he's the worst kind of person and so i
mean he's like he actually i'm my worst
worst kind of person i'm only joking
he's like um to other people he's uh
he's not pliable he's um
he really believes in the potential of
these uh
chinese soldiers to tie the japanese
down or to actually attack them and you
know donovan comes in and donovan is a
manipulator donovan's been manipulating
for years he's he you know managed to he
squirreled himself into positions his
entire uh you know since since he got
that medal of honor he's used it to you
know
plow pathways through bureaucracy
and to create a unit that never should
have been created to create this oss and
and to
and some of his schemes are completely
hair brained um but some of them are not
some of them are actually you know
pretty good so he when he sees donovan
he's trying or when he when donovan sees
miles he first wants to you know put
miles under his thumb
and when miles can't be put under his
thumb he tries to take the whole thing
and leave miles with the weather
stations that's all he wants to leave
miles with he wants to take this entire
guerrilla army that miles is starting to
build
and he justifies that because miles is
you know like like quote in the book
he's not putting scalps on the barrel
head fast enough and he almost does it
he gets real close but
the thing that stops him
is the chinese won't work with donovan
but they do like miles they can smell
the intent yeah
right absolutely donovan is freaking
shady
it's tough to you know i guess he's got
to be shady a little bit he is i mean
he's i mean he you know it's tough to
not you know respect on him and he's
he's a character like
uh and he you know
but he's a he's a he's a toddler with a
with a flamethrower
all right can we go back real quick yeah
there's two characters that i want to
talk about from the udt i think that
okay
uh alan gordon leslie
uh
i was i was thinking about uh
um the contribution of other um
other branches of service to the udts
alan gordon-leslie is a marine uh that
gets attached to clt
to udt5 he becomes draper kaufman's
executive officer of udt-5 for the
battle of saipan
he is
he's canadian
and i was thinking about him the other
day because we're here in san diego and
i was walking through the hotel del and
i was looking at this you know this you
know monument to you know victorian
architecture and everything and it was
there you know during world war ii
and uh gordon leslie he goes through the
entire war he um he's one of the scout
snipers who seizes the pier at tarawa he
shoulders a a flamethrower and uh
assaults the entire pier so that there's
this there's this pier you know cutting
into the the lagoon that tarawa and uh
and that that pier would have threatened
to cut into the flank of the uh the
marines that were landing on the beach
so the marines had to take it before
they landed so they sent a scout sniper
platoon to do it and gordon leslie was
the guy with the flamethrower and he's
fighting all you know pillbox to pilbox
or uh in placement to emplacement and uh
you know um using the uh the
flamethrower to destroy guys while he's
got a machine gunner to his left and
they're going down this incrementally
taking the entire pier um
he survives the battle of tarawa and he
becomes uh he volunteers for the udt
um as sort of a marine corps liaison but
he falls in love with the udt and
manages to stay with them and the marine
corps completely loses track of them
they don't know where he is they think
they think he's a casualty he stays with
udt5 uh throughout the remainder of the
war and when he ends the war he tries to
transfer uh from the
um officially transfor from the marine
corps to the udts he wants to stay with
the frogmen that becomes so
controversial it goes all the way up to
the commandant to the marine corps the
marines say we're not losing a marine to
the navy especially to the udt we're
we're going to keep him so he's entitled
to like four thousand dollars with the
back paid because he hasn't gotten in
three years
so in uh
in retaliation he takes his four
thousand dollars he goes to the hotel
dell he slaps that four thousand dollars
on the on the front desk
reserves a peninsula of rooms um in the
in the dell uh and he throws a two-week
bender
that's so bad that draper kaufman has to
put up a watch bill of officers to make
sure that
his frogmen don't leave that wing of the
of the hotel
good times and who's the other guy you
wanted to bring up uh norman or uh
seymour owens commander seymour owen so
one of the um
one of the uh the great things about you
know doing the research for this book is
you get to discover all of the uh the
characters that weren't seals or that
weren't frogmen that contributed to the
um
the importance or the uh the success of
naval special warfare one of those one
of those that's always stood out to me
is commander seymour owens he was a
destroyer skipper
and he was involved in the
the fire support mission
um prior to the invasion of tinian so
tinian is the greatest strategic
battle probably of the entire central
pacific campaign it's the island that
ultimately becomes the uh
the airfield uh that they uh you know
fly all the long-range bombers to to
bomb japan on
uh that's that's where the enola gay
takes off from uh to bomb japan it's a
perfect uh table top island um
but before it can be that it has to be
taken and one of the biggest uh
coups of the war is draper kaufman's
reconnaissance of the of the beaches
that nobody ever thought anybody could
land on but in order to sell that in
order to land all those troops on those
beaches that nobody expects
udt7 has to stage this elaborate
ruse
on the south of the island
at tinian town and so
um
on the day of the actual invasion when
all the marines are secretly sneaking
into the uh the beaches that draper
kaufman has found um
the udt7 is you know conducting a
daylight you know reconnaissance and
they're protected by you know multiple
battleships one being the uss colorado
another colorado has light itself up um
midships are a
with a broadside uh to the beach
and it takes a devastating
um
uh
naval gunfire shore gunfire and its guns
are knocked out and the suddenly all the
swimmers of udt7 are exposed and they're
they're about to
the japanese are about to switch their
guns away from the ships they're
defending them to the swimmers in the
water now seymour owens is the
brother-in-law of draper kaufman
he sees what's happened he sees that the
colorado's guns have been knocked out
and he commands his ship without orders
he commands the norman scott to get
between the colorado so one the colorado
can escape
and two so he can also protect the udt
swimmers that are in the water
suddenly
the uss norman scott becomes the center
of all japanese naval gunfire and it's
destroyed
i think 47 sailors are are killed in the
process
including seymour owens but he does it
because he knows how important it is to
draw the japanese attention away from
those beaches in the north
anyway
damn
um
how are we doing we're doing
i'll tell you how we're doing
we we're we're gonna stop for today uh
that's the end of world war ii right
um and and again um that's the end of
world war two we hit some of the wave
tops
we there there's so much more incredible
information in the book um
get it but what we'll do is we'll just
we'll just record another podcast um
actually we'll just do it after this one
so people can stay in the groove on it
but i think that's about it for today
because we're looking at we're already
where are you three hours bro
at least real close to three hours
so
uh thanks for coming out ben appreciate
it um
echo
what do you think any major you know
things you need to bring up oh no
nothing major it's just interesting to
hear all these
all this stuff that was going on under
my nose the whole time under your nose
under all of our noses the whole time
uh hey if you want to support the
podcast
you can do what i'm i'm i'm drinking
some go right now probably how does that
go tasting i you said it was in the
middle you were in the middle of uh
telling me cool stories and then you
said it's delicious you got mango mayhem
right there you know that's echo charles
it's got his own signature flavor that's
how cool echo charles thinks he is
my first time i don't think i've ever
had a
yeah an energy drink well you know what
it's starting to get yeah you're
probably not going to sleep a bunch
after you drink that bad boy so if you
need some of that stuff get some jocko
fuel jackalful.com uh that's where we're
selling this stuff also vitamin shop's
got it going on yep wawa's got it going
on for the drinks
you know we have
we have uh ready to drink milk coming
yeah that you'd be able to go into a
store and just grab a cold
mulk out of the fridge salted caramel
ever heard of that
salty caramel's definitely a thing we
got chocolate vanilla
um
uh banana cream so the perfect mix we
got a mix coming your way so we got that
coming uh don't forget about your joint
warfare and whatnot krill oil what else
originusa.com american-made stuff
american-made stuff in our economy going
in the right way
it'd be real easy it's really easy i was
having a conversation with someone the
other day like oh you know
uh
oh they i saw another brand like that i
was like no you didn't
no you didn't there's no other brand
like this yeah there's no one else
that's doing this
if someone goes oh you know we're gonna
get into the uh jiu jitsu market cool i
take
seven thousand dollars
and i
order some rash guards from china and
get them printed
cool now you've got a brand bro no
that's not what i'm talking about we
invested our lives
into this
into
buying the equipment
capturing the know-how you know you talk
about how some of the people that you
would
you have interviewed that have since
died
uh and and you wouldn't have been able
to capture that knowledge we've actually
had that happen at origin people that
the old timers and i mean that with all
due respect the old timers the people
that knew how to run a loom the people
that knew how to work on machines the
people that knew how to weave and knit
they passed this information out some of
them we're losing them now
so
if you started a brand for you know four
thousand dollars by ordering some stuff
from china and slap that
hey good for you that's fine no no no no
but let's face it it's not too good for
you
uh don't do that you want to support
a real company an american company go to
originusa.com we're making everything
you need by the way jeans boots
t-shirts sweatshirts rash guards whole
nine yards so check that out
originusa.com it's true also jocko has a
store oh hunt gear too oh yeah i know
you're seeing it coming and
i know you like to wear camouflage pants
for no reason echo charles to be
camouflaged well i mean just saying
you're that dual used kind of
survivorless
prepper
you're like just in case i gotta go into
the
jungle i'm gonna be ready to rock and
roll we got this pattern there's a
little bit of a tribute to our
forefathers the the pattern that we've
made for camouflage is
you know obviously the primary goal is
to make sure it's effective but we were
able to make it effective ben while
still
giving a little bit of uh of uh of a
shout out to to the tiger straw to the
tiger stripes so
you know one we got one for the one for
the highlands sort of the western colors
and another one for the
more like the eastern colors so we got
like a woodland versus a
more of a highland camis but yeah a
little bit of tiger stripe activity it's
common both viable for me both viable
yeah because you know you you never know
what you're going to get into
whatever i wear i wear the heavy the
hoodie snowboarding yeah viable viable
lately viable oh yeah right over there
there you go awesome chocolate store
called jocko stores where you can
represent where you get your shirts to
represent discipline equals freedom
good
other stuff just a good way to represent
on the path when you see somebody else
wearing this kind of stuff you know
you know you know what's up uh subscribe
to the podcast don't forget about jocko
underground we appreciate your support
we just got done recording one this
morning it's going to be a long day in
the office today bro yes sir yes sir if
you want to support jocko underground
jocko underground.com check that out we
got a youtube channel
we got some books
primary book i want to talk about buy
water beneath the walls
look ben straight up i was being
straight up with you before
probably not the title we would have
gone with you know
it's hard to say it's a mouthful we have
no idea what it means
did you read the you read the of course
i read it i get it there's a tie back to
whatever battle took place 9 000 years
ago and you want to make that's the be
yeah plus he likes the wordy yeah you
know i know we're actually surprised
we're actually lucky maybe that was the
short version of the title
oh you should have seen the other you
should have seen the options i had for
subtitles
hey hey let me tell you um all kidding
aside this is an absolute this is an
incredible book it's it's
it's an incredible book the the
knowledge that it will give you is
phenomenal it's also
it's also really funny you've got you
you've got your sit over there with your
little dry sense of humor um and that
that dry sense of humor just shines
through throughout the book and it's
it's dramatic it's funny dude it's like
a
you know i feel like a commercial for
some weird uh summer movie you know yeah
it's like funny sad
you'll laugh and you'll cry
and that's the truth honestly in this
book you'll laugh you'll cry you'll
learn a phenomenal book
don't sleep on this book
and and you know there's there's an
audiobook too who reads the audio
book do you know some random act or some
dude no i can't believe i can't remember
his name um it's not keikoh it's uh
uh
kaleo griffith's
name i i listened to i listened to the
sample just to kind of see what we were
dealing with yeah we're freaking good to
go um yeah
so you can get the you can get the uh
the audiobook as well and sort of like
you you won't you'll feel like you're
listening to a podcast or you'll feel
like it's very engaging
so yeah they did it
support this book uh
ben put seven years of his life into
this book i don't know how bad your
eyesight got reading through all these
things but you've you've made some
sacrifices to get this book done and and
as i said the first time you're on
there's no one
in my opinion
uh
a non-seal couldn't have written this
book in my opinion um
and and i think the fact that you serve
the fact that you're a combat veteran
that you're in the seal teams is
you have a perspective that that comes
through that an authenticity that comes
through it's just it's just a phenomenal
book so buy water beneath the walls
by ben milligan get that book
immediately you already know all the
books i've written so get some of those
too
if you need some help with leadership
inside your organization you want to
talk about decentralized command
let us know
echelonfront.com
and uh if you want to go check out some
battlefields we do an awesome
battlefield review
we do get you you been to gettysburg
yeah we do gettysburg no kidding we're
also yeah if you want to come let me
know
uh and we also are doing little bighorn
this year so
if you want to check those out
go to go to ashlandfront.com next muster
is in dallas wait is that the next one
no we just did dallas next one's denver
so we got a bunch of those events we got
the online training academy
which
you know that thing i started this thing
off talking about how you can't get all
the lessons learned across to everybody
that you want them to
and that's one of the reasons we have
the the online
academy extremeownership.com
the goal the mission of echelon front is
to teach these lessons to as many people
as we possibly can that's the goal
me
leif
jp
dave steve we can't get around to
everybody but you know what everybody
can get online extremeownership.com come
and learn
these lessons of leadership
so that you can use them in every aspect
of your life every aspect of your life
you can you can help you you can help
yourself um if you want to help service
members you want to help active
active duty service members you want to
help
retired
service members you want to help their
families the gold star families
any of those if you want to participate
in an awesome charity mark lee's mom
she's got an unbelievable charity
organization
america's
mightywarriors.org if you want to
volunteer or if you want to help out and
don't forget about heroes and horses.com
micah fink
keeping people out of the algorithm
getting them back on track
as far as echo and i go we're both on
twitter we're on the gram
echoes adequate charles i'm at
jacqueline watch out for the algorithm
where what's your what's your instagram
handle
call sign b milligan three b milligan
three i think you should have made one
longer than that
i'm on
the twitters and the wi-fi oh you're on
twitter too yeah okay is it the same
thing then three ben h milligan on
twitter
ben h milligan on twitter
awesome um
hey
seriously thanks for coming on again
thank you i appreciate it this is
fantastic it's always great to be here
and and thanks for writing that book
thanks for reading that not not only
that but thanks for you know
it uh
this it took it took a lot to do this
and i'm being able to give this back to
the teams was you know
you know this is this is why i'm here so
this is my contribution to
you know that institution that you know
defined us so
100 man awesome um
and we'll we'll pick this up where we
left off on the next podcast thanks all
the military personnel past and present
who
laid the groundwork for
progression
who laid the groundwork for what we were
able to do
via your lessons written in blood
so thank you and thanks to
all the police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
out there
thank you
for what you do on the home front so
that we can be safe
and everyone else out there
man this story right here that we're
talking about is about opportunities
about the looking for opportunities
it's about taking ownership of what's
going on in your world
it's about seeing where you can help out
it's about seeing where you can fill a
gap
that's what this is about the seal teams
just didn't sprout up
from nowhere into this fully blossomed
flower
didn't happen at all
happened one piece of dirt at a time
to build up into something that's
worthwhile
that's the way life is
and the only way that happens is if you
go out there
and get after it
and until next time this is ben milligan
and echo and jocko
out